two
happy monday everybody
[Music]
excuse me
couldn't get that out before the show
august 15th
another beautiful summer day it's hot
tell you what
uh hellofresh thank you for sponsoring
us we love you welcome back a.b
thank you thank you glad to be back your
pr your presence was was missed last
week as well as lena's welcome back lina
too
thank you it's good to be back
you guys went to uh detroit yeah how was
it
it was fun it was uh interesting i feel
like i need to get charged up at least
once or twice a year and then i'm so
grateful to be out here in la so
it was nice did you meet a lot of tater
tots out there
yeah i found out a lot of my friends are
tater tots that's
crazy
girl
caused some [ __ ] and dipped
did you uh
i saw you message you said something
about your dad having a new family that
was pretty interesting oh yeah yeah it's
very interesting i met my dad's
girlfriend's kids
and it was super [ __ ] weird can you
pull that post up yes so
yeah so what happened your dad
your parents were recently divorced yeah
they got divorced a couple years ago but
all you kids are growing up right
yeah so was it painful for your parents
to get divorced that yeah definitely i
feel worse for my siblings but uh are
you the oldest i am the oldest oh you
are
oh yeah
it's still on twitter here i'll send it
okay wait why did you change it were you
feeling bad i
my dad is a uh important person in our
hometown and did he see it no he didn't
see it but i do have a lot of people who
uh
a lot of people in the community on my
instagram he wrote he wrote
my dad got a new puppy to match his new
family
i was like whoa that's kind of juicy by
the way that dog is so freaking cute
yeah really cute dog is that a
labradoodle or a
what is that i don't recall lena do you
know where can i get one yeah i know i
don't know what breed it was but they
their other dog was like this really
enormous dog so they got rid of that one
and got this tiny one what do you mean
got rid of that one well no they
explained they gave it away to um
i'm killing i'm kidding
so they found another family who has
another dog that size the same breed um
and they thought yeah he would be better
off with that yeah is
to clarify this is the second new dog
that my dad's new family has
and the first one my dad made sure he
had a new
home
i did not [ __ ] my dog all right i that's
okay i i that's good for the best
wilfred the dog but if some if this dog
goes but he gives this dog away too then
we gotta we gotta put the kibosh for the
new dog
actually i'll take this dog if he uh
is looking for an owner someday what a
cute dog your brother looks just like
you too that shit's funny as hell dude
yeah you know he looks like he looks
like a b crossed with the
the dude from game of thrones
um huh
rob stark interesting i see it right
yeah
i see it
yeah so you're the oldest hello your
siblings uh my brother is five years
younger than me my sister is four years
younger so wow dude i didn't know you
were like the
patriarchy of your family almost i wish
yeah not even just my immediate family
my extended family too
always putting the pressure on me that i
have to carry on the ayat name
are you
are you living up to that at the moment
yeah now i am my dad says he's always
been proud of me i'm like [ __ ]
all of a sudden he's always been proud
of you yeah i had the same thing with my
parents
we've always been proud of you no you
weren't
but it's fine yeah okay good so you're
carrying on the ad legacy that means you
guys have to have kids pretty soon
my family's not asking lena's family is
asking all the time
literally every time every time and i'm
like dude we want a dog and we're not
even sure how we'd have a dog here just
because you know we don't have family
out here you know it's just you guys you
couldn't bring it i know you said we
could bring to the other you can babysit
your dog too if you want
and maybe yeah
no i we love the dogs
our dogs love dogs we love dogs theodore
loves dogs
cab everybody loves dogs yeah melina's
never had a dog she doesn't know the
responsibility that comes so wait lina
wants the dog and you know so it's yeah
i want it but it's just a lot i mean and
we have a studio apartment you better
try some privacy i have the exact same
dynamic with ali listen she really wants
a dog and i'm like me too but
we just got you just gotta go for it i
vote dogs for everyone
thing is i had we had that same
hesitancy with shredder
you just gotta go for it
the thing is you guys are good plan to
have kids you better just go with a dog
first yeah
i think it's a good time they're way
[ __ ] crazier than dogs people saying
get a cat uh both a b and lena are like
deathly allergic to cats yes yes it's
horrible
cats are not i don't know this guy i i i
don't like to say it you guys know what
i'm gonna say also cats give you like
brain diseases oh
[ __ ] yeah dude what's the [ __ ] that they
get there's parasites in your brain from
cats literally yeah what's it called i
don't remember toxoplasm or some [ __ ]
the parasites are blocking my ability to
talk
yeah they make osmosis plasmosis bro
this [ __ ] gets in the brains of mice and
what happens is they let cats eat them
dude they just go up to cats and let
them eat them you got you have parasites
in your brain dude from cats
anyway they're nice though
i've never had a cat so you know what
i'm sorry for the cat slander i just am
a dog person i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry also the thing i don't like about
cats is they'll they hurt you they claw
you like all the time dog my dog doesn't
hurt me
yeah cats are kind of they're [ __ ]
crazy-ass claws and they're clogging but
i love them
whatever but you know what it doesn't
hurt we love the cats love me yeah i
think you guys should get dogs i think
both you guys should get dogs bring them
to the office we have a dog friendly
office yeah
maybe oh my god i bring my dogs all the
time
yeah ian just yesterday got in my ear
about oh this mic is not working uh
about getting a pet chinchilla can i
bring a pet chinchilla to the office cam
you're getting more and more foliage i
almost can't even see your ass i'm gonna
show up and you see a full bush in front
of you i love it yeah
you've got we need you to eventually
look like the homer simpson meme where
his head is coming out of the bush yes
right slowly
oh i would love that can i get a bush
outfit that'd be great we have a ghillie
suit here actually oh where is it i'm
gonna go put it on it's it's in one of
those uh bags
i should warn you it's covered in rats
and [ __ ] the old caps per hapsburg suit
right uh what the giant [ __ ] it's called
a hapsburg
you know i think that's not my size i
think about hapsburg yeah that's what
it's called
it's the one we made for the uh runway
show you're talking about all right
everybody
yesterday let me show you just one of
these like things where like a park
ranger wouldn't be happy if they knew
you had it i don't know look at this no
they're fun watch you give them you give
them the special dogs
they have so much fun i want a little
dusty boy i think alfredo would try to
kill him no
maybe i'll keep him in a little backpack
on my back
filled with dust
i think my dogs will try to kill that
cute little thing
they have they have like some
alfredo has crazy like prey drive
against little creatures they are
rodents so he's cute though they're very
alfreco oh yeah oh alfrico mode
okay
so anyway back to abey's dad having a
new family because that's interesting
so
your parents got divorced
your parents got divorced a couple years
ago yeah and that's been hard are any of
your younger siblings living with were
living with them at the time uh yeah my
sister was
so that was probably difficult yeah and
she's back and forth right now with them
depending on who she's arguing with
but yeah
no it's weird it's weird like lena's
family is all very supportive and loving
and just positivity and it's like me and
my family and friends it's just like
every time i see them it's like another
like crazy situation
yeah
i had one friend who i accidentally got
in trouble in a way and he had to sleep
out at our house for three days during
the vacation
budget what happened
his girlfriend has always been kind of
uh mean to him
is a nice way of putting it she doesn't
like when he goes out this friends or
anything controlling yeah very and we
were in the car together and uh he
called her and didn't realize that the
call was gonna go to the bluetooth in
the in the car
and uh she literally just answered and
was like
like screaming super loud and then like
he got embarrassed kind of just looked
at me and i was like
i don't know what the [ __ ] came over me
but i said uh hi yeah we like to place a
carryout
he said oh carry out yeah i didn't i
just was trying i don't know i didn't
know what to say it was just so awkward
so you're trying to say i'm here in the
car basically yeah but i was just trying
to be funny about it and then uh that
led to a whole debacle and he got to
leave the house and sleep he got kicked
out of his house for that it it
escalated from there
wow good times though good stuff
so wait why did your parents get
divorced
they got divorced because
they got married really young
and
i don't know they were still kids when
they got together yeah but what happened
they were together since they were 14 i
happened me and lena found out my last
trip that i'm a bastard
how are you a bastard you have a dad i
mean they were
i was conceived before i had a web yeah
okay they still did not you're a bastard
like uh game of thrones bastard yeah i'm
like a jon snow like cool bastard but
your dad didn't disown you no he didn't
insult him yeah yeah he threatened me if
you're not yet
so your dad was he having an affair or
something with this woman because he
moved on really fast uh
the details are spotty okay i i kind of
think he was but i don't know for sure
it's unknown yeah the timeline doesn't
add up so wow that's crazy so he moved
on
with a new woman did they they got a
house together beautiful house wow you
probably never grew up in a house that
nice huh i know we had a one bedroom
apartment when i was really young i mean
when i was older by the time i was in
high school we had a nice house but wow
yeah it's weird is his wife's way
younger
she's close in age to me wow
this is incredible yeah by the way are
you people are saying stop are you
uncomfortable with no no no no no no no
i'm not at all no i mean about all that
amy would tell me to stop if he was
uncomfortable so you guys shut the [ __ ]
up let me do my show
you know you know you're interested in
this just as much as i am
so wow and and and
and so did they have kids together yet
or is she pregnant or what's going on
she has two kids oh she has two kids
from a previous yeah thing okay and
what's weird is the younger one
was kind of looking at him and i told
him i was like you think that little
bastard's my brother because he
looked like me a little bit is he
he's young he's like yo
you might have you have a half brother
over there yeah i don't know we got to
get you got to steal some hair and
[ __ ] crunch the numbers on that
yeah
shit's weird
my parents were so strict growing up and
like we were like had like a we had to
represent ourselves in a certain way in
the community and we were always being
watched we couldn't do anything
and uh it's just weird now that they've
like
went the opposite way completely and is
your dad's new wife halal
uh she's white she's just white yeah is
she religious no
okay my dad's not very religious either
okay interesting
huh
and and can i ask you a question
i don't know how to ask this in a way i
guess guys i don't care no i'm not it's
not i'm worried about the optics right
now uh oh
i'm not worried about it i'm going to
say something i don't know
i shouldn't maybe there's just it's not
a good question put in discord you could
ask it
you're saying that i have an open book
is she like a tr is you get trophy wife
vibes from her
um
well my mom is very and i'm not just
saying this because she's my mom like
she's very pretty like my
my mom and dad are both very good
looking um
kind of contributes to them being the
way they are in a way but no i don't
think because my mom if you could argue
that my mom looked like a trophy wife um
your mom is a beautiful woman yes okay
here it is i asked in chat is she hot
lina thank you said yes she is
goodness
that's that's less it's oh
yeah thank you
no problem but my mom's hot too that's
the thing yeah but not she ain't she
ain't 20.
just kidding don't kill me i'd never do
that
it's a mommy make out there well how old
your mom i think what it is
is your mom still a hot ticket oh yeah
she's my mom's very pretty like my whole
life my friends even my own cousins
would tease me about my mom being hot
by the way i had the same [ __ ] thing
growing up bro yeah all my friends
wanted to were saying all nasty [ __ ]
about my mom my whole life yeah [ __ ]
it didn't really bother me it's just
nasty
yeah it bothered me when i was younger
but then when i was older i was like i
don't know why i let it piss me off so
much when i was a kid
when i was younger
dudes used to come hit on my mom all the
time in front of me
it's very young it's just yeah and then
it's always like the first thing friends
say to me when they come to my house
dude your mom's hot yeah
it's like so don't i don't i don't care
you don't need to tell me that bro
i think with my dad and then his new uh
his new fling his new girlfriend is that
my mom's girlfriend his girlfriend yeah
okay but they live together have pets
together i don't know it's weird but my
mom was very strong-willed like my mom
grew up my mom's very tough like my mom
and like
my dad could get irritated working or
whatever it is and make little comments
i know every dad but my mom will not let
that [ __ ] slide
like so i don't know i feel like he just
likes uh the peace of mind of everything
so
so you're saying this this girl doesn't
talk back to him yeah she's more like
she's more passive wow interesting
and is your mom dating she is yeah she
is she had to get my dad back she's
dating a jewish guy
take that
he's really nice though
jewish guy huh um what's he do for a
living
he's a very successful commercial real
estate let's broker
[Music]
the jews
so good for your mom ultimately she's
getting some good jewish dick okay okay
she's getting all right all right all
right all right all right
sounds rich too right he's rich
uh yeah he is
[ __ ] yeah it sounds like
it sounds like they're both doing well
at least you know yeah i'm more worried
about like impacting my siblings but
yeah
but they seem to be having a good time
wow that's a lot to deal with i didn't
realize that your home life was so
tumultuous in fact you've been here two
weeks or two years when you moved here
all this [ __ ] was going down back home
huh yeah wow
i want to see a picture of your mom dude
i can send you one
i don't know though after that last
comment i'm just kidding
come on these people are
everyone's judging me
uh
olivia
olivia has a fun idea she says oh i got
a picture of oh my god amy just sent me
a picture of his mom
all right let me open this compilation
of it
it was her birthday
um
olivia said you guys bring pictures of
your parents and i have to guess whose
parents they are dude that's such a fun
idea
mine you don't want to
no it's just that i i look exactly
like my dad in particular like you would
like you would look at it for like half
a second yeah
we could give
like both parents and then you have to
mix and match
like i think it's this one plus this one
equals dan
i love that idea so i'm looking at a
picture of abe's mom very beautiful she
looks a lot like you too
in the face yeah
happy birthday mom
slay queen
slay
the top comment is what your mom is
white
thanks yes that was okay all right thank
you uh for opening your heart to us abe
we all are going through things and uh
wow well there you have it
there you go we learn anyone else's
parents going through some [ __ ] you want
to talk about on there
my grandma has to mention i want to talk
about that
no
that's a little sad that's too sad right
now let's not talk about that
but sending love to you and your family
thank you thank you yeah sending love
you know sometimes
i watch you know i'm watch the real
housewives i'm a sucker for that dumb
[ __ ] show
by the way thank you bella simmons for
50 gifted subs thank you for the gifted
thank you gifted well thank you and i
could i see a lot of divorces almost
it's kind of insane every relationship
on that show
except maybe one or two
of the dozens they get divorced
i don't know if it's the show i'm sure
the show doesn't help
but i also think that a lot of these
relationships are rocky to begin with
because it's a lot of like trophy wife
stuff
but after they get divorced i have to
say a lot of them
seem to find themselves happier you know
so it's kind of interesting they all end
up with new significant others and it's
kind of interesting to see you know it
gives a little hope out there for
for them there you have it
good luck
thanks let's get to the [ __ ] war now
but welcome back you guys were missed
for sure thank you thank you
who's richie your dad or the jewish guy
hmm
i don't know
i don't know
can't tell you probably the jewish guy
let's [ __ ] go
do you know how she met him was it a
dating website or like
real life
i
i don't know how she meant to be honest
did she did she join jewish date jewish
men or some
jewish date you guys like swapping arab
before judaism
that was a real thing at one point
wasn't it due date yeah
my brother was on that [ __ ] for a minute
yeah he's married now obviously but j
date jewish dating
there's probably halal date too i mean
right there's got to be oh yeah there's
a muslim finder.com there's a muslim
finder let's go
dude that could go sideways a website
like that muslim finder let's find him
yeah last time it's actually run by the
fbi
[Music]
that's funny when i brought my camera
around my hometown everyone thought i
was with immigration he kept asking me
this past week
all right let's move on thank you a.b
so obviously guys the title we find
ourselves in yet another war i'm trying
my best to be a changed man i mean
i'm trying so hard to leave the beef in
the past and do
and to overcome
but people keep stepping to me
they keep [ __ ] with me
and some aggressions cannot stand
okay there's a line in the sand you do
not cross
sound the [ __ ] warhorn
now why do you make me keep doing this
shut up peanuts by the way um this
thursday teddyfish.com
now why do you make me keep doing this
man
legit you know this guy gideon
let me pull this [ __ ] up
why am i still getting hate
yo you gotta see this [ __ ] did you guys
save the thumbnail
oh yeah you got it this mother this dude
here
wait where's the picture of the
thumbnail
this dude so if you guys may not uh here
let me show you a picture he's a twitch
streamer
i really don't have a problem with him
yeah
okay good i don't really have a problem
with him we talked about him a couple
times one of them he went to like the
quote unquote most racist
town in the usa
and basically was like
yo check out these white supremacists
they're not that bad
yo these kkk guys are super nice
and anyway we just we crit we
lightly criticized him for that
and then we watched one of his old
videos you guys remember it was when he
went shirtless to best buy and started
like
[ __ ] with um
an employee there
and we called him a douche but look at
this thumbnail bro
um
he called it gideon reacts to h3 showing
liberal racism on his podcast
that's so i was like okay if you want to
say that i'm like a liberal racist i i'm
i'm willing to
hear you out because obviously i don't
want to be that
but he he doesn't
he doesn't really say anything about it
uh but look at this thumbnail
he shows me saying
look at him acting like an orangutan
what the [ __ ] bro is that some crazy
[ __ ] to rip put on the internet
just pulling that out of thin air
that's just too wild isn't it
no i'm not easily offended to be honest
and
people say a lot of [ __ ] about me
um
so at this point i'm i'm used to it and
for the most part doesn't really bother
me but this thumbnail actually did
bother me because when i saw that
i was like what did i say something like
that
because that's kind of an insane thing
just i mean it's like straight
defamation bro
look at him act like an orangutan
with a text bubble coming out of my
mouth
i was like hell nah dude
um let's watch the video a little bit
that pissed me off though dude you want
to pull it up yourself so you can yeah
be pausing
actually he unlisted it i don't know why
he he unlisted it recently we saw that
he had a uh strike on his totally
unrelated to this um uh given to his
account um and so he might just be
unlisting things to avoid uh
controversy and avoid trying to get
another strike yeah he just got a second
community guideline strike jana's tick
tock too he said is
is down
oh he lost his tick tock too gee i can't
imagine why
that might have just been that he had a
video taken down from tick tock though
not yeah right it's just all happening
right now i just can't imagine why this
guy keeps getting in trouble
he's so responsible he just always is
very thoughtful before he said stuff
but okay i'm gonna be i'm gonna try to
be delicate because this is the new me
right
so here he is reacting it all kind of
takes place in the last part
he's reacting to
us
reacting to us reacting
very meta yeah yes
um but what is part of what is he
reacting to
oh it's not even new no it's he's
reacting directly to us
shout out to homie man let me find out
you're part of the prd nation bro
bro leave leave something like this bro
ethan you inspired me
all right he ain't going to be like hey
man you got to put on the shirt real
quick i've been like yeah that's cool my
bro came up to me like
yeah you guys remember this by the way
his shirt says professional wrong dogger
it's like i mean you can accept some
criticism that you're a little immature
dude
you know what i mean
it wasn't that mean what i said oh hey
what's up with your boy andrew
my brother was trying to hit the wall on
me like kind of felt violated
andrew yesterday
you discriminated me
you did not let me take off my shirt
boys he's loving it look he's laughing
at his own video
still love it it's still a good one boys
uncircumcised
[Applause]
this is
this is an iconic moment
in the judeon lore
this is an iconic i feel like bro
this is something ethan would have done
pre-2018 pre-podcast ethan literally
would have done something like this
this is one of my favorite things
detractors say about me i didn't but i
didn't
you know it's so easy to people love to
be like you would have hated yourself
today or this is something you would
have done but i didn't do it
i feel like you would have made an h3
video making fun of this video yes
the people they there's no line the
people people can just create this old
mythical me that somehow condones
everything and and and
it's [ __ ] insane i never did [ __ ]
like this i never did
i feel like they're referring to things
like like the vape nation video or or
like the thousand shirts going into a
store like those kind of videos that you
used to make but i i don't recall you
ever like getting in the face of
employees
that's exactly what was great about
those videos is that i was the [ __ ]
butt of the joke nobody else was to be
fair to gideon he says at the end of
this clip that the guy andrew who he was
like targeting in best buy he
ended up being called him and like
bought him a camera and stuff
cool but that is just in in defense yeah
no i'm i think that matters to an extent
i think it does yeah that he you know
didn't it was afterward but sure off
camera
i mean
well regardless yeah like those videos i
used to do were always me as the butt of
the joke and by the way like vape nation
i always got permission to film in
people's stores like when we would go
and well the grocery store would not but
i was just wearing a bunch of shirts
what's wrong with that right there
wasn't really like but like the vape
nation one in the vape store you know we
we got his permission to do it
was all very nice and amicable
yeah and definitely i feel like every
time you re-watch those videos you
always say like how uncomfortable you
are and how much you hated doing that
kind of stuff
yeah you weren't looking back like
[ __ ] yeah
well that's one of the reasons i stopped
doing those but anyway this whole
[ __ ] notion of like you would have
done this video it's like i didn't
you know you can say i would have
[ __ ]
gone on the corner and jerked off like
cody coney but it never happened
yet
give it down maybe i will pieces of [ __ ]
like this could come for me
coney coney 2024 baby we coming back
i don't i don't care what anybody would
say pre ethan would have done something
like this bro ethan you inspired me
you want to know why i act the way i act
is because of you ethan it's cause of
you
because of idubbbz because of joji
yeah and all three of those guys you
just named
well
filthy frank would have done some [ __ ]
like that probably although you guys
would be surprised by how respectful he
was to
behind the scenes everything was pretty
consensual and set up there
but like we never did this so i don't
know what you're talking about dude
it's cause of y'all
you guys were my childhood
you then then i seem uh uniquely
positioned to tell you
don't do that
then it seems like i have a pretty
strong authority maybe one of the only
people that you should [ __ ] listen to
when i say don't do that right
shout out to brad dude29 who's spamming
andrew tate is a sex trafficker
okay love that side note love that shout
out brad dude29 gifted
yeah so listen to me bro you know what
i'm saying yeah
i have some respect for your goddamn
forebears
yes you ethan
you you over here looking at me like
this you created this
okay
no
prank i mean he's more inspired by like
pranksters than me don't do any [ __ ]
like this nice try
[Music]
[Applause]
this is like milk boy vibes i like when
did i ever do anything like this you
could argue you made a career out of
calling this out yeah like
yeah this is like [ __ ] like [ __ ] tier
2005 youtube prank stuff dude
come on man
nice try
jdm reacts to h3h3 showing liberal
racism on his podcast okay i can't wait
to get to that
it's simple is he standing on a bunch of
expensive suvs we are peaceful
andrew you can't run from this we will
not be caged any longer
we have
[Music]
join us sir
can you please join us
why not it's simple
it's simple
free the nipple bring a nipple
[Applause]
i i i guess i'll just go to a time stamp
says again
[Music]
bro look chad you can see the old ethan
you can see the old ethan like ah that i
like this dude you can see it man you
can see ethan come on man come on ethan
bro
you know you like it ethan man you know
you like it bro come on
come on ethan man
you can smile for once i know you have a
whole new demographic now if you were to
laugh at this you would get canceled on
twitter but ethan it's okay man
it's okay bro look look you can see the
the happiness the proudness in his eyes
he's like i created
i walk so you can run you're just doing
shitty pranks yo
listen i can concede when something's
funny this was not and i like how he
thinks like i'm the only sour [ __ ]
about this i found this video because i
had like 50 000 points on i'm an [ __ ]
subreddit yeah no it was
freaked out i believe one of those i
think it was on i mean this maybe it was
cross-posted there too i don't know
i mean you said at the time and i think
it's true it's like
whether or not it's funny to have a
bunch of people show up at a best buy
and start chanting like that is one
thing
the the main thing you took issue with
is him
targeting that employee
dude that was so like that that's where
it like just becomes kind of douchey
yeah and like chasing him and [ __ ]
showing his face and i don't know the
whole thing was pretty tasteless and
lame
you know if you want to do a prank on
best buy i frankly don't even have a
problem with that i mean right i'm not a
prankster though never been a prankster
but go up bro yeah
according according to all these people
that hate me now 2016 ethan was a
prankster a racist a white nationalist
a god
the funniest man alive
yeah
anti-social justice warrior
pro alex jones
uh people in chat are saying dark ethan
dark ethan let's go dark ethan
yeah bro you can just con but i like
that people don't allow me to speak for
myself you know they i hear that all the
time they go
ethan what a
hate this is something ethan would have
criticized
ethan would have criticized himself
today
bro
let me in this unique position as ethan
to say
i never did and i wouldn't and here i am
i'm telling you
you know i'm the guy you're talking
about
it's just weird
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't know she was kind of [ __ ] up
to target that guy yeah he was just
trying to be a pretty light criticism by
the way very light i'd say i'd say you
were off that day you're tired or
something
i was expecting you to go in on it
good employee yeah i wasn't targeting
andrew shut up dude just own it how
about some accountability
you're immature bro that's fine you know
i used to be immature also you [ __ ] you
can work on
how are you even gonna deny that i was
targeting the policy that the store had
in place you were doing both stop
just because your fans are 12 doesn't
mean that i'm 12.
what you're saying doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense
but me andrew are cool andrew actually
thinks it's hilarious
that's the thing
it didn't seem like he did he was
literally running from a mob of people
as you chased him and shoved that mic in
his mouth
but okay i don't you know good friend
i'm glad that you guys sorted it yeah
man they sorted it out and it's all good
it's the same [ __ ] ricegum said the girl
was okay with me making the did it feel
good though joke like she's okay with it
it's fine yeah every time yeah when
these pranksters get called out they're
like the other party was fine that's why
i kind of shrug when you're like oh he
bought him a camera it's like well yeah
cause everyone [ __ ] on him [ __ ] said
that this was [ __ ] up so he's like i'm
gonna go try to be cool with him
if nobody cared i don't think he would
but whatever maybe he would
not here to make assumptions about this
man
me and andrew are cool
literally i posted a picture of me and
him
i was supposed to show this on this i
was supposed to drop the video on the
second channel
but i actually
bought andrew a camera i was like you
know what andrew bro you gave me such a
banger video i was let me get you
something i said because every time i
see him i'm like bro let me buy you
something he's like no no no no no he
was finally like i want a new camera i
was like okay bet and i literally bought
him like a three thousand dollar camera
i bought it for him and he was like
thank you
i know and he was like thank you
damn he he was that appreciative
he may have been i don't know
maybe he's you know i could i could see
them working something out after the
fact yeah i'm sure they're fine yeah
again and that's good that he did that
right yeah it's good yeah like we're
cool man just don't bring another army
of shirtless guys and call me my name
with the megaphone and my workplace
making minimum wage right cool
there's nothing funnier than harassing
minimum wage workers like that's
something that i've always been about my
whole career
you know always famously
in fact gideon
i remember going back to the god of
cringe
i was making fun of him because he was
[ __ ] with starbucks employees
minimum wage workers so right
you can go back to that time i haven't
heard in a long
time not a cringe god of grinch holy
[ __ ] we shouldn't have said his name we
just invoked it i know he's been in the
reply spirit is back
you remember he was doing the god of
cringe was doing a news show like butt
ass naked yeah just but right just right
above his dick line
you remember that love
yeah i do that's good [ __ ]
bad news right
bare news
oh it's called bear news i think
so i don't remember quite
what is that i don't understand what you
the note maybe
you understand that joke
i'm kidding
i'm saying that his next thumbnail is
going to say ethan klein says he's black
because you oh dark ethan yeah yeah
cultural appropriate i promise on
everything y'all that was before i knew
about this h3 video it wasn't me even
trying to like clear my conscious or
anything making minimum wage probably
you're just trying to be a good employee
and you all had to [ __ ] with them like
that and call them out by name you know
i don't know
bro
again bro that's the lightest i've ever
roasted anybody ever
i think jillian you're obviously
immature and that's fine you need to
learn to accept some criticism that's
good that's how we grow you'd be like
you know
i can see that how hard would that be
but you go oh i wasn't targeting andrew
shut up
we know he's capable of that because he
did he did uh
kind of back down during the whole um
remember he had the whole beef with
pokemane and they ended up washing it
and everything yeah yeah it seems like
he's
capable of reflection so i don't know
maybe just
well they don't harass employees anymore
the really fun part comes at the end
here so we're working towards it but
yeah that was good how he made up with
pokey i thought that was dope the
redemption arc i feel like ethan
cause ethan goes harder on people
he's not going as hard as me as he could
have okay no but
you could tell there's some part of him
he probably didn't like everything that
i did but you could tell some part of
him kind of liked it it wasn't funny
no part of it was funny
in my opinion
dude but he was shirtless not funny
he was shirtless he had a megaphone
like i pr what i do appreciate is the
effort you know like i like the
execution of it and organizing a big
group of people to be in on it like a
flash mob kind of thing yeah i thought
that you know i thought that execution
was was impressive and good
but i didn't like the
the thrust of it
it's not funny
but i got to be more sensitive because i
i i like him he didn't do anything like
really bad
except you know defame me and the
thumbnail which is kind of [ __ ] up
really [ __ ] up
also it's like bro i don't know if you
know this but
best spy is not the only place you can't
go in without his shirt oh wait it's not
no you're lying ethan
i thought it was just best buy right
pretty sure that's everywhere
and he has a lab mic on him so well why
are you feigning surprise you literally
just said you were going after best
spice policy for not allowing people to
come in without shirt
and not andrew
i mean the joke was that you went after
andrew and it's fine but just own it he
has someone following him with a camera
clearly they know
he's there to [ __ ] around
what
all right let me go to the part that was
the end where he
goes too far with it
um
i'll skip forward a little bit here for
you guys ethan but i know you guys watch
his podcast bro you can stop the cap so
what's brody's name
oh yeah i like this part he calls dan
wan yeah w dan
yeah in fact
there i'll go back look in fact the
video was hilarious jillian i'm just i'm
just backing up is he your best friend
yeah bff's material right let me go back
because he says he does compliment he
calls dan wan which i'm which is dope
for you dan i'm proud i'm happy for you
but by the way i was on board with the
redemption arc stuff too
bro
oh let me go back
pre-redemption arc again yeah you know
man look at over here that's my man
w man's bro
[Laughter]
chad you guys are over here saying l
ethan but i know you guys watch it so
tell me who brody is so i can say thank
you
you guys are saying i'll eat the l eat
them but yeah i know i know you guys
[ __ ] hates me it's awesome
you know
yeah but they love dan so
don't go too hard on the chat
[Laughter]
although he probably
i'm the one who brings up the kkk video
so he probably switches up on me real
quick i didn't i didn't see that far
okay good good
so what's brody's name
dan they know you damn w dan
w dan wan
w-a-n yo you should grab that zach when
okay that could be useful
good chat y'all
fellas can we get wayne's in the chat
guys w dan whan see i like that that's
good
pre-redemption pre-redemption arc again
yeah you know yeah it's true
he has redeemed himself
he's redeemed
yeah
now he's just running interference for
the kkk now you brought it there bro are
you gonna you're no longer winning
yeah this is actually so this is where
he gets mad okay now now you're laying
land land when
some days you're land some days your
land yeah
much much more minor than yeah he's like
bro i went and met the leader of the kkk
he's actually a really good guy he
didn't shoot
yeah so again
he was i really i think that's a really
valid criticism of that video he made
sorry he went to the kkk
and he was like look how [ __ ] cool
they are basically or how nice they are
anyway right
well sort of he
i think that to sum up
his message is like oh they're
you know people think uh they're awful
and everything but i was able to go have
a conversation and it it it sort of had
the attitude that like if we could just
break down barriers and and speak maybe
i could convince him
to not
hate me for the color of my skin when i
think that's incredibly naive
um
atlan you know
switching it up on you yeah go off king
like so this is like the leader of the
kkk or some [ __ ] i went to the most
racist town in america if you guys
church or maybe if maybe i can even
attend
a church
service okay it is a racial church
oh it is offshoot of
israeli identity usually yo yo yo don't
bring my people into this let's see
where it goes
because gideon's like oh they're
interesting because i thought you guys
hated jews and he's like wow
oh yeah hold on a second
i love how he's more respectful to the
head of the kkk rather than andrew from
best buy
interesting i think this guy's just the
head of like some [ __ ]
podunk towns like a little chat by the
way again or whatever not the lead
racist again i challenge you to find any
white supremacist that doesn't look like
some [ __ ] backwater hick
like find me one handsome white
supremacist
you know what i mean like nobody's
trying to [ __ ]
no wonder you guys don't want to
intermix like once you open the pool
you're never going to get laid again
because the women are not going to want
to date you [ __ ] missing tooth ass
[ __ ] river boating
catfish eating
camo wearing
mountain dew drinking yeah [ __ ]
dip chewing goofy ass
some people that find themselves racial
they don't like jews and stuff like that
so that's kind of like a
it's kind of well we're brothers in that
you know who the kkk hates jews and
black people man
we're brothers in that
we got a band together bro
they hate us both
shocking to hear well we are not jewish
jews is not the chosen people
uh
that the white race is do you have
anything to say to the boys and girls
out there
oh thanks for
listening hey dude that is such a dub
for him
thanks for listening all my white
supremacist propaganda also all right
i'm opening the stage brother what would
you like to say to the millions of young
people watching amen
the white rice
i really think he was
he was trying to do something good here
yes i think
yeah it's very it's very naive to think
that you can
break down this guy's racism by engaging
with him here's the mic brother
yeah that's what i think why he gets so
defensive about this video is because he
feels like he did something really good
and interesting and mature
and i acknowledged that you know
but
maybe if he hadn't made content out of
it you could argue that like if he just
personally went that'd be funny and
engaged with these people i mean there's
a very famous story of a black man who
befriended a kkk guy and he did change
he turned him around actually and i
think he turned a bunch of clan right
and so
i i think i think it actually is coming
from a good place but the platforming
them and i mean that video has like 10
million views now or something and dude
if you look at the comments it's all
these people like wow it's amazing you
know these guys aren't that bad it's
just like ah
that's not
it's not good it's not good to spread
that to a bunch of children that the kkk
isn't that bad it's not good yes so
that's my problem i think he's just
daryl davis is the name thank you love
of the guy who
he's just not quite mature enough yet or
maybe he just needs people
who understand this look because i don't
know just passing the mic off to a
[ __ ]
a kkk member is there anything you want
to tell the people thanks for listening
i mean that's [ __ ] wild yeah that's
pretty bad it's pretty bad but the white
race is do you have anything to say he's
like nah [ __ ] kill them jews the white
rosters
well anyway thanks for listening i am of
course
a white supremacist thanks for listening
y'all the boys and girls out there
oh thanks for listening
he's like man nobody ever let me talked
about this [ __ ] so openly thanks for
listening
if you all want to come to a meeting you
know where to find me
woohoo
appreciate you guys for tuning in oh
also um is it bigger than black and
white
yeah
what effect one will eventually poison
the other
it is bigger than black and white
all right thank you for your time all
right
ah that was
that was something damn you gonna throw
up on their property
brennan saying
that's how much brandon hates her well
there's one moment in this before i get
to the what he actually said i just kind
of want to set it up here for ultimate
irony
uh hassan was the one that showed me
about this
and hassan was making the same points
that we are and jitty and
lost it he hated that hassan was saying
this [ __ ] like this but i came here with
the heart to come with that and i
appreciate you coming out with the heart
to have that same conversation with us
you know what is yo zoomers are there
anything you want to say bro zoomers are
unsalvageable dude i swear to [ __ ]
god i know that people are going to turn
around young gideon fans are going to
turn around and [ __ ] yell at me and
be like he's black you're
not what the [ __ ] do you know about
racism or whatever the [ __ ] but like god
damn dude
just straight brain broken if you're
like oh what a civil conversation this
dude's literally a [ __ ] white
separatist man he just said it he said
it openly like he's part of the clan
bro that's your [ __ ] problem bro
like okay yeah oh god there's this is a
whole
uh how many times conversation hopefully
someone reacts to this yeah actually and
that's perfect because my window's in
the top right yeah there's one more
corner so yeah we have one corner
who's gonna take it
corner besties
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] in the clan
[ __ ] it okay who i don't give a [ __ ]
bro he literally that's a crazy thing to
say man that's a crazy thing he doesn't
does he just not know
the history of the clan what that means
he doesn't know what he's saying this is
a violent this isn't just like this
isn't just average racist like if you
want to like engage with just like your
average maga guy
like
okay
but
the clan lynches black people the clan
burns down synagogues they
this is a violent
you know white supremacist group it's
it's
you should you shouldn't care you should
care that he's part of the clan you
should care also these people actually
influence things i mean
you see people in government who aren't
as openly
racist violently racist but
these people influence things it was up
to them
race
marrying someone of a different race
would be illegal
you know what i'm saying uh teaching
like judaism and and in school would be
illegal they want like a christian theo
theocracy
so you should care like dan said
it's pretty wild that you don't but
again gideon's 21 so that's kind of what
yeah that's and it's fine
it's fine i just think
he needs to chill a little bit like you
can't [ __ ] throw out [ __ ] like ethan
is a liberal jew with me saying he looks
like an orangutan
so you're i don't care racist liberal
not white racist
here that he's in the clan and stuff
like that i just wanted to have the
dialogue and i got the dialogue i got
the dialogue i had the conversation me
and him we shook hands we parted our
ways i don't i don't care if he if he
doesn't respect me i don't care and
stuff like that we had the dialogue
that's your problem is literally you
heard that he was a kkk member boom oh i
cannot hear anything nope it's like bro
i think that's pretty fine though it's
like i'm a nazi
is that cool tell me tell me about
yourself
but there's nothing wrong with having a
conversation right with nazis or kkk
members but i do think you need a
baseline
of knowledge and a baseline of
understanding of of what it is you're
putting out there to help responsibly
engage in that conversation
which is why for example i removed my
jordan peterson interviews
knowledge
you know
i promise you everything that just went
through this conversation
went in through one ear and out the
other
all you all that stuck was he's part of
the kkk bad yeah what's interesting is
ultimately what he's doing is defending
a clan member right now yes
yes he's like yo this guy's a good guy
bro
this guy's a nice man
get on his ass case clothes and stuff
like that i want the conversation that's
all i wanted that's all i wanted yeah
but there's also a thing like having an
open dialogue with people like clan
members or nazis legitimizes them in a
way
it shows people that they're worth
engaging with in conversation
and
their position is like a non-starter
which is like death to jews and black
people you can't
yeah there's no middle ground there's
exactly there's no like i mean they wrap
it up they have they have optics right
they have pr they know how to say it
without saying it
death to all jews the keemstar knows
hideous but so
unironically turns into a great example
of how racism is insidious but so
um so apparent and and very much a part
of people's lives because like
if your takeaway from this is like oh
well look actually they're not that
racist at all right like look at that
if your takeaway is like looking at a
guy who showed up says he's a part of
the clan and is a white separatist not a
segregationist and your takeaway is like
he can
or not your take away but like your
takeaway should be
that even a guy who's like straight up
saying like
uh you know that they're a white
separatist
can be polite to a black person to their
face okay that does not change the
reality that they're like violently and
virulently racist especially when they
know they're on camera
yeah totally this is for this is the
best pr moment for him
he literally got to like platform his
ideas
and get almost like
with the kitty gloves on
and then
he goes yo what do you want to say to
the people thanks for listening
boy i sure do appreciate and also death
to all the jews
all right thanks for listening y'all
yeah
i just want to say to the young people
of america we need to round up all the
jews they are in charge of our banking
system our government
and all the new world order
if you look at every major war
i bet there's a jew round behind
it it's not okay
so in short i want to say we need to
kill all the jews thanks for listening
[Music]
jillian's like wow
what a good guy
man we love that
by the way hassan pretty brave for this
because this video was like mega viral
and everyone was loving it and he's the
first guy that was like this shit's kind
of insane
so he went into the viper pit with this
and he's right
nathaniel clans we're in here
yeah we have a noose here just for
decoration
it reminds us of the good old days
not that we would ever use it
but it reminds us
well i sort of like that oh you like
like you know this is why i'm taking
away from it
just because he didn't you're basically
saying to me
what i like this is this is how i
personally feel this is how i feel like
bro like this isn't like factor this is
all opinion this is how i feel what
you're saying to me
is
i don't understand basically what's
going on in this situation
that i just had this this was a 45
minute conversation that we cut down
that in this 45 minute conversation i
have no idea what was happening and
stuff like that and i need to yeah
the reason i'm watching this is because
he goes he accuses hassan of being a
liberal racist because
of
honestly he doesn't really ever explain
why but here this is what he does here
so back to the original video i know
this was a long tangent
much much more minor than yeah bro i
went and met the leader of the kkk he's
actually a really good guy he didn't
shoot
bro i went and met the leader of the kkk
he's actually a really good guy you guys
okay now that's a funny joke
i mean come on bro
i'll just having fun this video but that
actually pissed me off oh really
that actually really pissed me off
there he goes defending his good buddy
the head of the local kkk
you know you went 2-4
this is my good buddy nathaniel klansman
he's a great guy
and i'm going to get pissed off about it
jenny just can't stop defending kkk
members
really pissed me off actually
guys
4k this is liberal racism
4k this is liberal racism and the crazy
thing about it is they they can't wrap
their minds around what liberal racism
is
in their minds there's no way a liberal
can be racist it's literally impossible
definitely definitely
i mean liberals can be racist as [ __ ]
and often times are
let me let because so i'm open obviously
if somebody's like oh you're this is
racist what you're doing i'm open to
listening
that's obviously a huge accusation to
make so i just want to really listen
hear him out here get it they and they
never will they never will get it
is that us or him he might close him i
guess you think we could
so that's it he doesn't explain why or
what that even means it just seems to be
that because i'm criticizing him
i'm a liberal racist
and actually he called it 4k so it must
be super obvious
but what's crazy about gideon is that he
accuses me of being a liberal racist
and then this
[ __ ]
has the pull up that thumbnail again
from that short clip
people were sending me this thumbnail
look at him act like an orangutan now
bro this is so [ __ ] up on so many
levels first of all you're putting out
this racist trope
okay you're putting it out there
you're attributing something
horrifically racist
with a chat bubble meaning i verbatim
said that
also
it's kind of interesting how gideon is
practically
because he's gone full circle and become
a social justice warrior
because it's like
everybody
he sees everybody's he's calling
everybody racist well
if i could stop you in his defense the
kkk guy he's okay with
yeah that right what i said was too yeah
no but it's like dude if you're gonna
call me races i'm interested to hear
what you've said and by the way i agree
that
liberals can be racist i don't agree
that they can't and i've son i've said
and done racist things and you know i'm
always open to hearing and learning from
it but the one thing that's super [ __ ]
up you can't put that out dude you can't
do that in a thumbnail that's insane
that's [ __ ] insane with the title
jaden reacts to h3h3 showing liberal
racism on his podcast
also like maybe he because it is
unlisted now which we discovered just it
like an hour before the show
um
is it
possible this is all the fault of like
his editor or something and
hell nah maybe even told them to take it
down
giving that possibility
because i do think we hadn't responded
to it yet and he unlisted the video so
like give me the link of the oh here it
is but i think it has more to do with
this the second strike
yeah it's i think it's the second right
because this is community guidelines
territory with that thumbnail right and
it may have been age restricted or just
matured oh he commented on it bro he
commented i told you yeah yeah
he pinned that comment i missed the old
h3
pinned by president
no plausible deniability for our boy
this is on gideon premium
and his main channel commented that
well there goes that theory that's
[ __ ] cold i was trying to give him an
out i know
it's probably the h3 haters they're
saying you already got your second
strike watch out he's gonna call susan
get you removed
all the conspiracy
i'm already seeing it a little bit yeah
call up uh call up susan
i'm not i didn't report it i'm not doing
anything i just think it's insane talked
about it until now we already know how
that would be possible
bro of course i'm gonna say it like why
am i the [ __ ] if he gets if he gets
why am i the [ __ ] for this [ __ ]
thumbnail like sorry dude
your age is showing and that's fine
let's read some comments i'm sure
they're good
be careful putting it on screen without
screening at first
you never know it'll pop up down there
h3 hating on creators becoming more
successful than him is nothing new
i don't
know what you mean by that
h3h3 humor
h3 propagates liberal racism thank you
gideon for finally saying what we were
all thinking
has been on everybody's mind
yo that shit's [ __ ] up bro that's
honestly that is literally defamation so
so here's where the part where i okay
this is the mature part okay this is
where i show my
my grace i'm graceful like god himself
let's get some gregorian chants going
exactly yeah let's get the vibes right
in my old age
i have learned many things gideon
the faults
of youth
is a given but it's what we do
when confronted
[Music]
that lets us age gracefully gideon
you're young you don't know what you're
doing
and so i'm willing to let this slide
just that you took things too far but i
do think it's important
[Music]
now
as you mature and keep making content
like i don't want him i don't want you
to get banned on youtube
you can't just let it slide please
[Music]
and actually i'll say i don't think you
did anything really wrong i think you're
a good guy and i think you're funny
and you prove that you can be mature and
squash the beef when it came to uh
whatever happened with pokemane that was
nice that made me feel good but i'm
warning you with peace and love
you take [ __ ] too far
keemstar is on twitter blaming ethan
virginians tic toc getting deleted is
that right yeah wait what did i do
it's it's not worth it's exactly what i
said i haven't even seen a stick talk
what was his tick tock
dude keemstar is the only one that's
actually writing youtube
like we know we have we have absolute
[ __ ] proof of it
okay
what what happened
i don't i've never i've never visited
his tick tock i don't even [ __ ] know
but it's typical
keemstar anti-semitism slash ethan
obsession
terrorist
um
but i will say gideon
oh
i think he just needs uh oh he said
gideon called out h3 yesterday
and today he received one youtube strike
it wasn't even for this video
the video is still up the idiot
like if he got a community strike the
video would be erased i have the
unlisted video open right now that's a
fantastic point idiot i mean
and it doesn't even it's not even age
restricted
dumb [ __ ] bro
jillian called out h3 yesterday today he
receives one youtube strike and his tick
tock band
bro you are so [ __ ] dumb does he
think that you have clout with tick tock
because ethan gets every single [ __ ]
video review post a single [ __ ] video
on tick tock i stopped i basically
stopped posting
so frustrating
yeah every video i post there gets age
gated
i feel very foolish
bro that's so nuts
especially when it's proven that he's
the only one that actually is writing
youtube and having [ __ ] done like but
anyway
i'm not i'm not i'm not wanting you to
get banned or anything crazy i'm just
saying what you did is [ __ ] up i think
you need to acknowledge that this
thumbnail was [ __ ] up you can't do
that to me or anyone
right
and
and you know i'm willing to let that
slide i am
[Music]
so
also if you want to also
if you want to accuse me of liberal
racism
i would love to hear you out if you want
to have a conversation about it
an open honest conversation i'd love to
learn how i'm being
a liberal racist because you didn't
explain it here
let the conversation begin thank you
garth
but i i do forgive you i'm not you know
listen
an apology would be nice but i'm not
going to demand it of you okay
you're you're good guy you're funny
you're talented you're 21 years old
and we love that for you in fact i'm
looking out for you
you gotta chill dude
do we know why he got a second strike
i don't think it was confirmed it was we
were hearing different things about him
reacting to a gambling stream right he
was saying that it was because of some
gambling stuff but he oh that's crazy
he says that he's adamantly against he
said he's against the gambling and he
was like reacting to some gambling stuff
and that could be a mistake then it
could be a mistake yeah but again that's
why steve will do a gut ban but actually
he should talk to keemstar because he
knows why it was for this video that's
still up apparently
stupid ass
yeah so anyway
i don't know that i love how he goes oh
this [ __ ] pissed me off and then
like
does that
people saying but is he a good guy or
you're going too easy on him i i i he
seems that he seems like he doesn't have
bad intentions right exactly like i
the worst thing i can say about that
clan video is that it's incredibly nice
yeah yeah i agree i don't i think he was
trying to do something good there
and just does not realize that all
he's doing is giving a voice to some of
the worst people in the country and ones
that want him dead and you dead that's a
real irony it happens to be the clan who
happens to be uniquely right well
black people and jews so you know we're
brothers bro exactly we're we're we
should be united man everybody hates
both of us well not everybody let's be
honest
you know but people [ __ ] hate jews
man
that guy
here's a question i'd like to ask him if
you could kill all black people or all
jews which one would you choose now
that's [ __ ] hard hitting pull
i'm kidding
[Laughter]
i'm not trying to do like the
racism olympics or anything but i bet it
would be jews
no no the clan is really the clan is
first and foremost about blacks did you
choose well we'll never know and i'll
tell you uh the clan historically at
least was also extremely um
uh belligerent towards catholics oh
really at the time when they were formed
the most of the immigrants from say like
ireland or italy
um or or
mexicans um they're primarily catholic
and the kkk is very like protestantism
only so they really just hate anything
that isn't them well maybe if jdm was
doing real journalism we could have got
an answer to that hard-hitting question
which one do they hey more yeah or which
one would you wipe off the face of the
earth they've killed a lot more black
people than jews that's i would say that
they're more racist that's true those
are black people
when we got w dan wan over here
shout out to emo
jalapeno
for five gifted subs yo that makes me
wanna eat nachos for dinner what the
[ __ ] literally i just saw not jalapeno
and i had a whole vision for dinner
that's [ __ ]
mental illness right there
god damn
think of the gifted
yes so but i think there's a road to
like squashing the beef i'd like to be
friends with him i'd like to talk with
him i don't think he has bad intentions
and uh and you know
he's
let's witty in it together within we can
do this
yes
okay so there you go you know
but i'm not overreacting right that
thumbnail he posted was and the title
was [ __ ] nuts right it's mostly the
thumbnail you know if he wants to call
you a liberal racist i mean the thought
yeah i mean the thumbnail and the title
in
conjunction i agree yeah
was so crazy i actually panicked when i
saw it because like i didn't say that
[ __ ] did i
that's like he says i said it verbatim
i could probably see you for defamation
if i was a petty little [ __ ]
i am a hater i am a hater ass [ __ ] but
not a petty little bit well i probably
am but i don't sue people i guess
you are you're very petty
but you don't if i was vindictive though
let's be honest there's a lot of people
i could sue
that i don't i'm not vindictive i'm not
i really am not
dumb
i'm thinking about suing them too
oh wait they're okay so hold on jillian
there was some great moments uh
that i wanted to show you guys
um
just so you know though we've gone very
long we we really gotta get to i need
that screen cap of him doing the salute
it's here
it's a it's a video link but yeah it's
it's just so fast
yeah
seeing it in motion is much more uh
sus than just a screenshot though so let
me slow it down
this was a moment did you cut cut this
by accident dan
uh
no cuz i was looking up that video
i was actually originally looking for
the video where he was arguing back and
forth his song because i was trying to
refresh myself on like what that whole
exchange was about and yeah i just
stumbled upon it i think in the comment
section of
his original video
because i was looking for a timestamp
and somebody was like uh what the [ __ ]
is this and then clicked on him was like
whoa
yeah it's pretty awesome that's a whole
video about racism
and now he's standing in front of like
it looks like a clan
run kind of building here yeah we should
note though that those those are just
kids from the local high school those
aren't like the clan members that he's
with right but actually they didn't even
throw up any
hails but here is gideon
let's go brother that was good form too
that was like a strong he hit that
he hit that hit the dab yeah he hit that
dab hard as hell boy
there's one where his arm is really
straight does he do it twice he does it
twice okay yeah yeah there it is don't
don't do that that's that's racist my
friend
that's actually never [ __ ] up yeah
don't do that and it's just so ironic
man
you're doing a video about racism and
you've included you doing a [ __ ] heil
hitler in front of a clan place [ __ ]
hilarious great content but he's saying
he's saying
anti-semitism is something we can all
joke about and have fun with right yeah
that's funny that's okay that's fine
that's okay
yeah i thought that was a fortnight
emote
yeah maybe
yeah i mean
again he's the king of removing
deniability because usually when people
get caught doing salutes they'll be like
oh i was doing something else but he
even hits it with one of these it's
pretty clear what he was doing
like here
[Laughter]
oh no
hey
i like this new fork dance this is a
horrible night dance what do you call
this
hey
hile tomato town so shut the [ __ ] up
don't accuse me of some [ __ ] racism
not explain it and then be doing heil
hitler's fortnite
so you know what
you know what
i still
stand by all the things i said but also
suck my tiny jewish dick too
gross baby
okay hit that music again
right chug what do you call that a chug
chug chug jug yeah with the chug jug
hit him hit me with that that's that
clan kool-aid yes
hey
hey throw them up hey
throw them up
yeah
yeah oh [ __ ]
[Music]
that happened right as i clicked on
what happened
it's getting all creepier
all right anyway you guys get the
picture
all right thank you kill it kill it
thank you
wow
all right we've been going an hour and
15 minutes we've got to do it thank you
to hello fresh we love them folks they
are truly
awesome
uh what is hella fresh you get farm
fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
doorstep
skip the trips to the grocery store
count on hella hellofresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable and
that's why it's america's number one
meal kit
savor every last second of summer with
hellofresh hellofresh delivers fresh
quality produce from the farm straight
to your door in less than a week
allowing you to enjoy the delicious
flavors of the seasons right from home
skip the grocery store and spend more
time soaking up those summer rays
hellofresh market is a one-stop shop for
all your meal time needs with a curated
selection of breakfast lunch snacks and
dessert
what is hellofresh super troopers
absolutely love hellofresh these are all
pictures sent in from our community
and thank you guys by the way for doing
that and this this food looks amazing
they send you basically pre-portioned
ingredients with an info card explaining
about the ingredients and telling you
basically step by step exactly how to
cook the meal so that it's oh what is
that
that caught
my that looks good tell me more about
that one
that's hella fresh baby what's inside of
it anything you want bam
look at those grill marks
i feaster eat your heart out
wow an abs burrito of course
yes so they send you pre-portioned
ingredients they tell you how to cook it
i've actually learned stuff i feel like
i'm a pretty
experienced chef
home chef whatever
and i picked up even some really useful
tips that i implemented today like one
thing i learned from doing hellofresh is
they tell you
when you take like a steak or
something out of the pack
you wash off the schmutz not to clean it
i know cleaning meat is [ __ ] you
rinse out the [ __ ] and then you dry it
with a towel perfectly dry it
so it's totally dry and then when you
sear it you leave a much nicer sear on
it so that's i asked do that now i dry
all my meats before i
throw them in a hot pan
i try that
super delicious man their food is
awesome everybody loves it it's also
nutritious it's healthy it's everything
and more it's the moment go to
hellofresh.com
h3tv16
and use the code h3tv16 for 16 free
meals
across seven boxes and get three free
gifts that's hellafresh.com h3tv
16. use the code h3tv16
thank you to hellofresh america's number
one meal kit
let's freaking go let's freaking go
yeah
[Music]
all right
so that's the well so there's actually
two wars to talk about today
yeah actually i when you said let's get
into the war i thought we were about to
talk about this other thing
yeah so there's that's one war that's
not even the big war though the big one
one more or two fronts
yeah one more one more two fronts that's
tough you don't want to fight a war on
two fronts no no
that kkk guys hero uh learned that the
hard way mm-hmm
hitler that's adolf hitler
[Applause]
let me ask you this dan did he open the
eastern front while he was being invaded
already
no because they did a d-day and d-day
was way later so the war was actually
almost
coming to a conclusion when d-day
happened we like to
psych ourselves and i mean it it
definitely helped but um
yeah uh d-day was in
uh 42 right and um
yeah so it wasn't his choice the
two-front war it was uh yeah he thought
let's let's be fair to port let's bring
more to fairness
i'm pretending i'm giddy in here
[Music]
anyway so um
okay so jimmy lee as you guys know
continues to have a rough redemption arc
to the point where we're pretty much
swearing him off right right it's coming
it's coming to that but here's the last
one dan went all out on poor jimmy lee
here it is
dan you're getting your shirts next week
and i even got one for dan who hates me
i really do you're an [ __ ] no
don't
you did it you actually did it are you
how are you feeling about that now that
you've sat with it for a minute
i i feel fine with it
i feel
i wouldn't i couldn't lie to him in that
moment yeah you know he always does that
he always like dan you hate me and it's
like i i i don't really like him and but
i would always be like i don't want to
hurt his feelings and i want to make him
feel bad
but
as as we'll see i don't want to spoil
anything but there there was an incident
that morning
on social media with jimmy that i had
seen that's what we're getting to left a
very bad taste in my mouth and so when
he said that i i did not feel like
protecting his feelings this time okay
okay so we'll get to that let's say that
i know and i'm all right with it
he's made his peace with that then
though so so you're good
by the way do we have all the memes of
people getting
angry at us for
oh yeah we do yeah yeah in fact the
subreddit has been torn
typically more of a civil war it is it
is a civil war and as you guys know a
country divided cannot stand man as the
great abraham lincoln said and i like to
always
compare myself to abraham lincoln as
much as possible
so let me be the peacemaker or if you
can't make peace i will [ __ ] invade
you
somebody says about me
ethan pities jimmy
like
frodo pities schmiegel
he sees a part of himself in jimmy
now i don't know about that
i don't know about it because that's
that's a that's a w sam's the [ __ ]
sam
that makes me dance
so i thought this was pretty funny i
don't know that i see myself in jimmy
though let's take a step back here a
little bit
i see my dad and jimmy does that count
um it con continues on another post says
we we hate [ __ ]
hobbitses we don't want anyone sniffing
around our precious unless they're
serious bingo
he was having fanfare
seven fan fans did you make this cam
yeah i did this is so [ __ ] do you
like his spray on hairline i love every
single thing about this this is so
clever
bingo
we're having fanfare ethan i didn't make
the reddit post though i just made the
meme there okay
uh this one got a lot of up votes
um
almost two thousand
i'm with dan no more jimmy he's just an
[ __ ] he doesn't deserve a platform
he's not even funny please for the love
of god stop having him on can i
can i submit that that's why he's so
good
like that's what makes him great like
we're poking the bear have you ever met
someone like him in your life
no he's a completely unique individual
and i'm not gonna pretend like i haven't
gotten a lot of laughs out of our goofs
with jimmy lee but when he is asking me
or stating to me
that i hate him i'm not going to be like
no i don't hate you yeah i i think he's
a dick yeah well he asked sometimes
don't ask questions you don't want they
know exactly
uh this top comment has a good idea that
he says
i loved other jimmy content but today
was cringe well
that's the that's the nature of the
beast
they said maybe we can watch them give
people root canals that's interesting
so obviously a lot of people are against
jimmy they stand with dan
but here there's other ones i love jimmy
600 points i've been watching h3 since
one [ __ ] up dennis days and it
honestly hurts me so much
that the h3 audience hates jimmy we know
he's an ass that embraces himself that's
why we love him i'm a progressive by the
way but i can understand jimmy isn't
actually oppressing people with these
shitty jokes
whatever happened to the h3 whack pack
peace and love we don't use that
that's trademarked
where would we be without our audio
[Laughter]
hold it
and somebody said i love jimmy in doses
biannual doses i i'm with you kyle kyle
brain that's interesting well guys
when i hear he's having a a fan meet up
for
the whole city of atlanta i gotta check
in on i mean and that's that's see
that's the news i thought it was great
again i think he's an [ __ ] i don't
like him personally but him calling in
being at a fan meetup where he didn't
tell anyone the address that's that's
[ __ ] funny that's he didn't tell
people the address no he didn't know he
said yeah
he gave them
very very clear guidelines guys i will
be i will be attending earth for the
next three hours three to six baby i'll
see you find me i'll be somewhere in the
milky way galaxy there's a picture of
the earth on our reddit and it was like
photo of the next h3 meetup
yeah somewhere on earth jimmy uh jimmy
texted me this morning his new endeavors
he's gonna start doing shows
see now that sounds [ __ ] interesting
and he's like he's like zach you gotta
do the shows with me i'm like no i'm not
doing that what does he mean by shows
fanfare
he's doing a show all right let's keep
moving oh why do i keep doing that idiot
oh wait no i do want to do that idiot
such an idiot i agree with dan another
one jimmy's an [ __ ] he says shitty
things people hides by the fact that
it's a joke then gets people into
feeling bad for him when they call him
out i'm all for ng humor but there needs
to actually be a punch line some of the
[ __ ] he says can be kind of funny but
just saying wears his camel to an air
person isn't a joke yes
spoiler alert but yeah ethan can and
should do whatever he wants with his own
show he's clearly good at what he does
well finally somebody says that
but i will continue skipping the vast
majority of jimmy lee content and i'm
sick i've seen people act like people
don't like edgy humor if they don't like
jimmy i agree with that sentiment it's
not about edgy humor or not
but there you go it's a very polarizing
topic here
um and the the civil war goes even
deeper than this we're leading to
something really shocking
[Music]
this was one meme i feel like i need to
defend myself a little bit here this had
3000 points almost hey jimmy do your
thing
h3 tell his offensive joke jimmy lee and
then i get mad
but the whole the thing was we brought
him on as an offensive
out of his mind comic and then we had
this really promising redemption arc and
so we're in the wake of this redemption
arc that has clearly failed
and i think that's
where
this last frame comes from you know
so
i don't know but maybe it's starting to
feel like that which isn't good you know
that's not that's not good if it feels
like that yeah and also it the label
says h3 which is you but it was really
me who did that so it's not really fair
to criticize you
maybe it's just a general label for
everything that goes on here yeah
but yeah i mean if that's what's being
perceived that's not good but we're
leading to something really cataclysmic
uh jimmy lee reminds me michael scott
people say that about me too doing a fan
meet up without giving an address then
rallying
rallying up the employees at a b-side
restaurant to make it seem like you have
fans
was a beautiful thing to see really gave
me michael scott vibes i totally agree i
thought that was fantastic
but here's where it goes off the rails
okay
we're getting there but jimmy
has been kind of moping around on on
social media would you say he's moping
yeah yeah he literally put a few photos
in black and white
he's kind of baiting sympathy now he
says they love me they hate me
you gotta keep going
and read the caption h3h3 make up your
mind
i'm the jers the jersey outlaw loves you
but do you love jimmy lee he texted me
this too he texted you that yeah oh he
texted me
he texts me he's i'll just watch the
show did not go well
i think it went well i mean it was funny
i mean
i don't think it for jimmy i think it
was kind of uncomfortable and i i
definitely contributed to that so i
apologize listen i couldn't i couldn't
hold back in that moment yeah he also
contributed to it he asked for he asked
you
he asked he asked you and he keep and he
that's like the 50th time that he's done
that and i've always i've always been
like it's okay sweetie i don't hate you
it's okay little baby this is like this
you're a grown adult but in a way i
don't like it in a way it's wrong for us
to keep bringing them on and then
ridiculing him well he's we
i agree with him gotta show progress
and he continuously reverts back
to the things that we have told him he
should not get a whole freaking i
personally love jimmy i have a soft spot
for him he's my bestie
but i understand people that uh you know
that are over it the problem is he's
getting a little too big for his shoes
right now he's getting a big head his
ego is tremendous right now he hit 11k
on insta and it
he thinks he's mr me marino and you know
like that's why he's reverting back to
this old-timey joke [ __ ] an old-timey
joke it's all cameo you know because
he's been doing this routine for however
long 20 years 30 years and no one has
ever to my knowledge liked it but now he
has people paying requests for them to
get [ __ ] on so he's like oh [ __ ] he's a
professional i made it they love it
and he's right man he did he is a
professional he did make it and i am a
fan of jimmy lee and i have been but
zach you talked to him yeah every
[ __ ] so do you have any um
any anecdotes of him getting too big for
his britches just
you know i i think it's great you know
he's making these memes but he come out
with this merch and
uh uh the cameo like a b said
i mean
he thinks he's he's feeling on top of
the world right now
you know and one one thing that kind of
surprised me is that he refused to send
us his merch that was a little bizarre
he he claimed that there was a mix-up
with some of the shirts and the ordering
process but he did eventually send him
he didn't send us all shirts he just
sent
five
which should be here he complained well
anyway so here's another one he says
[Music]
it's just me myself and i solo ride till
i die
my man
friends
are the family you choose h3 who's this
these memes are so [ __ ] nuts
i kind of love him to be honest i love
his
i think it's mason i love his his meme
game dude mason is on another level he
says my h my family h3h3 we love h3 but
do they love jimmy look at this one
so remarkable
he wrote not one of my proudest moments
with this in black and white that of
course was the faded
man i hate
little people little people yeah but
but hold on guys i promise there's
something coming up okay so here's where
the civil war actually breaks loose
as you guys know arab world news is our
new
news correspondent we love him he's a
total sweetie
uh here he is his recent video
uh hologram of field of dreams um
but he always
he always hits hard with something
again we just watched it now
hologram of legendary cops broadcaster
harry kerry things
take me
out of the ball game this video anyway
he's our official news correspondent
whenever there's breaking news we turn
to airball news
but i don't know if jimmy got like
jealous of our of our new i think so
um
our new acquaintance here but jimmy
started heckling him on twitter
totally out of line
look at this and you know this is a joke
we've talked to him about
everybody give arab world news some love
he's the most wholesome person in the
world this is i guess
uh our subreddit has a twitter i didn't
know that i think it's just a fantastic
fan that yeah retweet stuff from our sub
anyway
sweet
post wholesome everyone's happy jimmy
lee
he says
on this where's his camel at
where's his camel
now jimmy we've talked about this joke
yes this is like your go-to and we keep
you know but what did he do now now you
know arab world news is not one to sit
down and take it and this is where the
civil war
really begins not not i mean
to jimmy's credit i feel like he's being
informed of all these these things we
talk about on our show through the
people that are in his his team if you
will
so
trying to throw mason under the bus
right now a little bit
just to defend him jimmy just a little
bit um
how much do you know about mason not a
lot i just know that he's wrong we know
that he exists because he also
he also has a manager steve rossi steve
rossi who does not exist who is just
jimmy yeah he pretends to be somebody
else so maybe that's mason's steve ross
united talent agency steve rossi still
emails me
are you [ __ ] serious i get emails
from steve rossi every day
are you [ __ ] serious no i'm 100
i'll tell you when it was my last one
here
oh
god
stephen rossi let's see
jimmy knows
august 14 from steve rossi so yes that's
yesterday
is it
can i ask what is it is it like a pr
thing or is it it says the title is we
love h3h3 and it's a picture it's a meme
of him
with jimmy kimmel saying jimmy lee
appears in jimmy kimmel for the show of
a lifetime i don't know it's just a
stupid movie i know he'll send out the
steve ross emails for like his pr [ __ ]
like trying to get on other things which
he's done in the past
the last one was this this was um
july 31st so two weeks before that jimmy
ware
collections he sent me
a picture of his merch drop
[Music]
so yeah steve rossi just emailed me
yesterday shout the [ __ ] out
steve rossi can i ask you guys is air
world news commenting like on the cruise
like personal social medias at all
nothing i know that you know i've
noticed are you asking if he's a clown
goblin no he's been commenting a lot on
mine and lena stuff i didn't even notice
selena's the one that pointed it out to
me i wonder if the civil war he's making
his alliances
well he sees the fellow arabs yeah he's
like i need to get in good with these
folks we could write in our camels i
don't really look at my response i don't
know if you guys saw
i've only seen his drops on youtube on
his like youtube community posts
well anyway so arab world news saw
jimmy's response
because he's sharp man he doesn't miss a
thing
he says my h3 family if you want me
roast him hard say yes and you know
everyone's like
absolutely your match [ __ ] this
is civil war jimmy and arab world news
are fighting i mean who could have
predicted this timeline
and and i'll be honest
jimmy's the aggressor man he's russia
right now right
and again so just to clarify what i was
mentioning earlier this post of him
making the camel comment to er world
news i saw like an hour before we went
live so it was fresh on my mind and then
jimmy was like oh dan hates me i was
like yeah i kind of do like you're kind
of an [ __ ] you just like this air
world news guy he doesn't know what's
going on he doesn't know who jimmy lee
is you're just a stranger on the
internet making racist arab jokes to him
like he doesn't have any other context
man and he seems a little sensitive to
arab world news he's yeah he's been
thrust into stardom right and it's like
this guy's wholesome like he's wholesome
and he's a little sensitive yeah so like
leave him the [ __ ] alone man
but anyway he's ready for war which i
didn't ever see in this side of our
world news but i love it
he says you ready the first of all in
the top right please clap
which is when he tr he he thought we
were beefing please clap please clap he
says you ask me where my camel
here's my camel
what a stud dude i love it
seriously that's a great photo
hold on
here's my camel so run away before i
bite you i am the king
and here he is on a camel who could deny
it owning it yes you just got took the l
jimmy and the emojis too were such a
good choice
the flame
flame and crown yes also like sick
skills bro he got some nice he got a
nice border and backdrop
shadow yeah jimmy sweet like he came for
war it's a good graphic better meme than
macy's
[Music]
jimmy's gonna get him on the payroll
next watch
you gotta love this man had a pic of him
on the camel ready to go nah he [ __ ]
dude he's very photogenic too look at
this
holy [ __ ] no i haven't shown you
14 minutes ago is this a jimmy post
i'm so
i'm sorry i upset you
with my history on a personality
disorder
it's called a crop dad's not even in the
sun
this is like a pokemon battle going back
and forth with new attacks yo
and see again like i've i've said to
jimmy in the past
his self-deprecating humor can be funny
stick with that stop calling people gay
and telling arabs to not bomb him like
stop stop with that
hispanic people wear their papers yeah
and just [ __ ]
just roast yourself
it's funny people like it when you do
that that's what when we had him on and
ethan had that sit down conversation for
like i think an hour or something yeah
that was [ __ ] amazing
absolutely i think we're talking in
circles because we've had this
conversation with him so many times he
cannot change he has his ionic
personality disorder
work with me
i think he's watching right now because
he's like texting me he's like
shirt scent zacker my camel is parked at
zach's house
[Laughter]
i think
before
on again if we do
we should have some conversations behind
the scenes we've had we've we've
tried we've tried we've tried
there's no there's it's the ego right
now
people asking if he was diagnosed no
that's a self-diagnosis yeah he was
diagnosed which is something i'm
interested i want to kind of get he
refuses to go to therapy which is what
he really needs
sometimes when i watch real housewives
it seems so insane to me but they bring
the cameras into a therapy session
and i was like first of all
what therapist would allow that that's
weird they did that on kylie jenner's
show too
it always strikes me as the weirdest
thing it was so it might be interesting
to do that it seems like borderline
illegal but
i want to tell jimmy let's get you in
some therapy let's get you an official
diagnosis with cameras inside that's
[ __ ] interesting work with me
jimmy what do you think what's that mean
i will say though um he is funny when he
goes after people that are you know kind
of asking for a little bit like that kid
we met at the meeting yeah and he asked
him about the pit where the pimples come
from and all that and he just mumbled
his insult that was pretty good so he
has to pick his targets way better and
like you know obviously authorities
whatever notes we have it's like it
doesn't work in one ear out the other
and that's the problem that's what we've
learned here and that's why people feel
like we're stuck in this cyclical yeah
bringing jimmy on
making fun of jimmy being offended by
jimmy it's because
the man is incapable of changing and
we've tried our best
through love of the game
our love of jimmy himself
he he just asked can dan be his
therapist no dude
you need to go to a real therapist a
real [ __ ] licensed therapist who can
give you a clinical diagnosis jimmy
i'm not asking you to you know get on
medicine or
anything like
anything
like that i just want you to talk to a
person
he says yes i can
interesting
also if you could do wally's teeth that
would be the ultimate redemption art for
sure he said he was willing
yeah
i do want to still get wally out to
jimmy lee i don't know we need to look
into the logistics of that
because we'd have to rent like a
handicapped van and um it's a long-ass
drive we'd have to get you know plan his
whole trip for him
did wally ever get his money yeah how
much money do we spend on what race for
wally
um
we raised like 20 000 or even more like
thirty thousand dollars for walden yeah
we never even checked back in on him we
gotta talk to wally
yeah we should do a call with him i'm
checking right now to see how much uh
what was the final total
who was in touch with him
me well
i was in touch with his little his
handler so can you can you reach out
then we got to get them back we raised
12 931 out of a 5k goal
so let's let's let's try to get them
back and then maybe jimmy we can set up
the
the road trip of a lifetime jimmy said i
will do wally i promise that
okay
that's how we get the people back on
your side jimmy
can you imagine filming that i mean
there's like that's that's like once in
a lifetime compound
maybe he could do the one [ __ ] up
dennis bit while he's doing the
dentistry
so anyway
uh that's what's going on it's literally
nothing but nose saying no to that oh
people don't want him to fix wally's
teeth people want us to cut jimmy off
still pull do a pull do paul just say
bye jimmy forever
bye jimmy let's do three bye jimmy
forever
bye jimmy forever jimmy once a year me
once a year
love jimmy love jimmy
is that a bad pull
it's pretty he it's a good pull he said
he sent me another message but i'm gonna
wait till after the uh the poll okay
here we go whatever you guys say
this i'll stick to it okay
now i'm i want jimmy once a year kind of
guy not to influence
him you guys know i love jimmy though so
no surprise
guys you better get your votes in now
because it's neck and neck it is neck so
if you are passionate about jimmy
one way or the other get your votes in
the old times
take my wife please
[Music]
well
we've pretty much got the results here i
can say definitively at this point thank
you everybody for participating
uh
basically 23 say we love jimmy
which is assuming
reoccurring
uh next up by jimmy forever 27
but jimmy you'll be happy and relieved
to know jimmy once a year is in a strong
commanding lead at 50 and that's that's
what i feel too we just gotta dial it
back a little bit on the jimmy lee
content he said tell ethan i love you
guys and do not mean harm i try to be
tony that's all tell dan same tell dan
i'm okay it's just a character i do it's
not okay let's stop but it's a certain
it's cyclical it's the same thing yeah
yeah we gotta we gotta get out of this
we gotta go to the jimmy lee meme hole
it's been a jimmy lee summer
so okay jimmy we'll check in you gotta
you gotta wait six months you're on a
six you're on a six month timeout okay
well you can write some new material
from that time
and we'll be right back here
six months
yeah he's going to open with where's my
camel
hey
i missed you all right we're getting out
we're get we got to exit
stop
yeah but anyway this was real
interesting right air world news v jimmy
lee no one expected that that really did
catch me off guard
i guess i shouldn't have though because
you know arab world news did he clap
back at you and hassan yeah he came back
on me hard we ended up being a
misinterpretation and we we squashed it
but uh
dude he came back on me hard he's
willing to beef
because i was doing i said the the uh
jeb bush police clap meme
right and he came at me hard he's like
yo this guy has to ask people to clap
for him all right and i was like that's
true that's true without the context i
do look like an idiot please clap
well there you have it
uh up now we got other stuff
top of the show
for example
ringo starr
this man is giving it out for free
ladies and gentlemen
he
he posted a picture of his feet
wow
he's got peace and love sandals but
those are gnarly bro i don't even know
like
you know they're fine but he's just old
they look like old man
yeah i think
they look okay for his age it's just
it's just not what i want it's just not
what i expected
it's growing
actually this wasn't my favorite one
that was the he did that one second he
did this one first
he was trying to promote
he had to let us know who he was
obviously i don't get this photo this is
the one i saw it's an interesting compil
composition in it
uh he's too close the way he came back
his toes are scrunched so
so consistently on both feet
we could have gone half a size up don't
you think he's too small time to get
some new sandals ringo i know you got
the cash we've grown out of them what
happened here you got a little cut
interesting
interesting
we can have
c-man uh speak on this soon yo
send it to c-man wait did he ever
respond to the ninja
he responded
um
it was
i kept i kept trying him
and he responded and
let me just read you the email because
it pull up the enjoyed his response
someone pull up the ninja feed pick just
for the context
i think c-man is great because we can
just keep sending him feed picks
he didn't he did not comment on anything
he just
i told him
that we wanted to speak to him again
and that our audience uh
uh misses him and did you ask what do
you think about this feat no because i
was just trying to get a what
that was the whole point you got a
picture of ninja's feet and you say what
do you think about this feat i'm not
emailing him out of the blue after not
talking to him
because i wanted to get him on the show
to talk about it that was the goal oh my
god damn bruh you're insubordinate that
is a way that's
it's way better than just getting a
response in any dude you gotta be you
gotta be on the nose with a guy like
c-man he doesn't have time to [ __ ]
you say you say yo
yo
score these feet and ninja has a lot of
feed picks
where was the one that we liked that we
sent him
here's this one this one bro i mean look
at this this is like right this is
insane dan you've got to just send him
this phone did you even send him the
photo no i'll send it to you oh my god
i think i disagree with your approach i
think that's the wrong approach dude i
guarantee you that we're gonna scare him
off yeah but now we didn't even get a
rating for his feet i guess i get i bet
you he's going to come down with some
comments on ninja's
feet i'll zoom in the feet i'm going to
just
be like what do you think of this just
say real quick
can we get a raid out of here with that
i i
understand both sides but i feel like
sending him the pic
in the first emails like just sending
him a nude off the top yes exactly he's
not he's down with all that dude yeah
but we could
he's our boy we're we're on good he's we
understand each other
wikifeet
tyler blevins dude i mean i can't
believe this photo it's literally his
shield it's definitely right up his eye
he would have paid money for this photo
he gets it for free
just say hey real quick see man can you
rate these feet for us all right
uh he did in his response because i said
we wanted to speak to him and his
response was
uh
his response to are you available is yes
can be in two saturdays from now
i just thought that was a very
interesting can be two saturdays from
now yeah it wasn't on a saturday it
wasn't like that's just his way of
marking times how many saturdays it's so
funny that's what i'm saying he's a busy
man you show the feet are you asking
you're right on that front man all right
i'll say still want to speak to you soon
but we're curious about these feet
are they winners
no no say real quick see man
what's the rating on these feet
no you know what i mean
straight to the point
all right scent people are calling me a
foot pimp
[Laughter]
in chat
well if pimps are supposed to make money
i do this for love of the game
just do it for love of the game yeah i'm
not making i'm not cut taking any cut
off the top
yeah okay so that's interesting so
hopefully we hear back from him
yeah but that's exciting it hasn't been
two saturdays yet so it's possible we
this coming saturday will be the second
saturday so
okay great yeah i'd love to
wait what are you serious
i was on our conspiracy oh this is wild
dude
wait so well it has zero points so yeah
but that's comfortable it's still a good
uh rabbit hole here okay wait it was
crossbow oh to our server okay no i
didn't see this
so the find people at conspiracy or at
least one of them
says is ethan klein of hr using a fbi
confirmed pedophile symbol on social
media h3gate
spiral
i'm definitely not keemstar
okay whoa they put a lot of work into
this
[Music]
okay
okay okay
wow how do i even review this okay let's
start
so these are all different images yes
so is there any comment or just the
look at the circle bro i didn't make
this shirt you understand that wait
we're about to connect the dots i
literally you know i literally bought
this shirt from [ __ ] uh
uh uh
what's it called from some department
store okay jesus
[Music]
this is interesting i'm not gonna lie
so now you gotta go back i don't know
just scroll down
oh it's okay
okay this one cracked me
spiral on the inside of the pringles can
bro i didn't make the [ __ ] bro i
didn't make the it's not about what you
made it or not it's the fact that you're
putting all these spirals in all of your
social media posts for real
okay
[Music]
okay this one is so good though
oh my god
why do you keep doing this
what's your problem this is the lobby of
the
bellagio
that people take a gajillion photos here
and it's got all the beautiful like
glass work
stop it
talk yell at the veneti the bloggio
people
none
the [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god
dude if this had like more than zero
points i'd be really nervous
[Laughter]
yeah that'd be scary but somebody really
put this all together there's someone
scarily obsessed with me out there yeah
there's a few people somewhere there's a
few but definitely more than someone oh
this is freaky
dude it's a lamp behind me no that's
just definitive that's a [ __ ]
light a street light wow did that on
purpose
uh-oh
spirals in the chat
wait barrels in the chat people oh
proved it stop don't do spirals they're
going to come for me
[Music]
holy [ __ ] that's a street light dude
are you freaking kidding me right now
stop
couldn't be more clear what you're
saying i don't even remember where this
was
[Music]
sure you don't [ __ ] i wasn't
by the way it's from 2017. yeah you've
been this has been doing this for a long
time way back
this art dude
stop
i love that art by the way just because
i do it's awesome i love him robert
xavier dope great great artist
elis getting pulled into this
no is this a joke
there's no such thing as a coincidence
this has to be a joke right it's not a
joke
[Music]
this is scarily insane it's a joke to us
can you pull up the fbi symbols just so
i can compare
i mean i don't even know if that's a
real thing there's a spiral i've heard
of this before that there's like i mean
i've heard of it too but it's symbols
and stuff okay it's it's these ladies
and gentlemen we got them
are these now do people really use these
as the question right that's what i'm
saying is like i've only ever seen this
referenced in like
schizo posts like this
but like
it
you gotta be more particular with the
swirl i mean that's a common pattern
all swirls you can't just willy-nilly
throw all swirls in there
i mean i've been on social media for 10
years okay and you of course you're
gonna be able to pull swirls the puffer
fish right the one that turns into a
circle
my doorknob in the apartment i'm renting
and there's
bro
i got this is like a nice promo for my
instagram though
it's kind of fun
the background is just our tiny shitty
new york apartment
no i meant in the screenshot it's not
it's
yeah it's just
we were living in new york for a year
this was our tiny [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] apartment
such a dump
actually wasn't that bad we lived in
worst places but it was very very small
and actually it had swirled dude you
understand how common this doorknob is
you all seen this doorknob like your
life no i've never i've never seen that
before
anything like that in my life nope i've
never even seen a doorknob you guys can
get me killed you'll better [ __ ]
chill
this is scary
what [ __ ] even deny that one dude
what the [ __ ] man
where'd you get those blinds
it's not even the blinds it's the blind
anger it's like even more obscure
again a place where renting by the way
dude
people don't believe me but the coldest
i've ever been is in israel there's no
insulation
and all they use is tiny little space
heaters and so it doesn't really get
cold there because you know 50 at night
but it's 50 in the house the same
temperature outside is inside right
i've never been so cold in my house
is there electricity 24 hours a day
there yeah okay lebanon there's not
really yeah especially now
actually israel has a pretty robust uh
they have their own nuclear reactor that
that the it's pretty baller i guess oh
nice you trying to distract us from the
spirals
no no i'll keep going
that's rough what are they doing about
that lebanon's in a bad shape right now
man
they're bad but my brother-in-law was
giving me a little bit of a low down the
other day i don't want to say because i
legit think i will get whacked if you go
there no i mean if i even say this like
like the government there is just insane
that's con that's no why would would you
get whacked for saying that
certain
circles i mean people know that the
lebanese government is dysfunctional
yeah yeah and there's just
some crazy things especially with
electricity like i mean isn't hamas like
the governing governing body there it
depends who you ask it's
i don't know i'm not the right one to
talk on it it's just it's insane well
it's sad yeah you know
it's all sad what's going on there why
are you blaming for sure justin's
swearing and by the way this doesn't
even look like the swirl
uh-huh
where look on the cheeks
the cheeks oh here yeah
do you see it
bro what even did you circle
this is scary this person is super
obsessed like they went through
everything for real
whoa
that's the same try that you can't deny
that one it's the same hook
that they already used
and you're advertising it times two
lubing
oh my towel my bathtub oh dude
strange design for beth all just saying
me eating out jeff dunham [ __ ] off
this one they're like there's no swirl
in here i just want to see how [ __ ]
nuts just a stick photo
wait what the hell
the hell knows in these increasingly
strange days
same with this i guess they just think
it's super weird
oh they're like it's supposed to be kids
yeah yeah i see
no
they're supposed to be jeff dunham
puppets that we explained that in great
detail
wow that's really frightening
is ethan klein of h4 using a fbi
confirmed
pedophile symbol on social media let's
see what the comments are i'm sorry but
what the [ __ ] oh thank you
thank you jesus louise got me worried
there
all the comments you've made on reddit
are about h3 pack it up ryan you've got
trailer deaths to pay is that right is
this guy's
i'm scared look through his post history
kind of curious
is this
is this a goof
wake up
one self comment wake up too much wine
sorry oh [ __ ]
this is just sad you think this podcast
dude manage what the creator of rick and
morty wears he's just asking people to
take selfies in front of carpets with
the vagus of swirls just random patterns
seen in nothing this is seriously
deranged both of these aren't even
close-ups to a sproul it's just a curved
line
all of their posts are about you well
that's comforting yeah is ethan creep
uh
is h3 using cryptography in our videos
yeah we're getting there cryptography
what is that
no idea is it safe can i click their
user
uh and
well in the dock we have that one
actually if you want to click on that
this is a five-year-old
account too this is dedication this is
weird y'all
i've never gone into the rabbit hole of
h3 conspiracy theories like this
this is someone that was banned from the
discord and scorned oh you know who this
is no i just see their first post is
about being
so this was a member of our
an infiltrator you might say yeah
why would h3 have this meme on his
fridge
interesting
oh it's not up anymore um of course it's
not
[Music]
wait i never saw this one
is h3 using cryptography in their videos
pedo flag posted on tumblr
damn man that crypto [ __ ]
he had the he he had to turn it upside
down first of all wouldn't that make you
the anti-pedophile if it's upside down
some might some may say that
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is deranged
and i don't i don't like that oh that's
it okay so it's not that much
damn
yo you're in trouble
l fan
that cryptography [ __ ]
please
stop
thank you with peace and love
stop it
well that was a whole [ __ ] that was a
whole [ __ ]
nothing beef tricky
yeah where's your beef jerky i was
asking you yeah okay yeah so abe uh he
posted a picture maybe maybe we could
pull it up
of him outside
in a homage to keemstar's famous beef
jerky and syrup yes video it tastes like
beef jerky it was a b said i well i do
have a family butcher
i do yeah and you brought up you
procreated us some meats right
i did yes uh ronnie's meat market ronnie
market
my dad worked there when he was 12 years
old shout out um yeah he knows my whole
family he was asking about everyone in
my family renee yeah
i'm bring the meat dude i'm hungry
ronnie this is exciting so we have
curated
childhood meats
compliment of a b after that segment
that's kind of a crazy thing to say
some childhood meats make your heart out
conspiracy
yeah and are these made of baby foreskin
or cow or what
both
baby flesh it's like a neapolitan type
thing and here's the picture and will we
be eating this um with syrup baby
no syrup says abe
do you have a syrup guy
here's a b in front of ronnie berry's
halal meats ronnie
oh i made a funny joke about this photo
baby it looks like detroit's a rough
city you're standing on like a [ __ ]
blood stain
[Music]
thank you dan
extra syrup just in case the desire
is shout out to uh dan
shout out dan
[Music]
people are still giving money for sam's
jeep my god
[Music]
um okay this is we didn't really yeah we
didn't really prep this i just got off
the plane and came here
oh
those look good let me see these are the
og ones this is what
yeah people like in florida across the
u.s have these sent to them yeah here's
a
scissors so he delivers these uh
interstate actually people just send
them to family members
yeah
these are hot ones
yum you guys want to try this
oh yeah
you pass that around yeah i'm going to
try this hot one
so you used to get down with these
pretty often
my family loves these we go to town on
these ethan just out of curiosity what
is it what does it taste like it tastes
like beef jerky it tastes like beef
jerky
[Music]
honestly it's so good i don't even think
it needs the maple syrup
you know
is there more
oh my god
you're spoiling me
this is better hospitality than fishy
ever got yeah oh god damn dude so these
are two different types of beef jerky
yum
one of them is beef this one's beef and
this one is lamb and he oh he's the only
person in the u.s to have lamb beef
jerky oh don't know if that's true but
he's a good man i'm just gonna that
can't be true can it
maybe
shout out ronnie
it tastes like beef jerky it tastes like
meat
it is
let me try that lamb
the lamb is pretty good let me get one
of these he had me try it on the spot oh
my goodness
now what makes it hello
so hello is uh
so like kosher meat you say like uh like
you bless the meat in a way
and also it's the way in which you uh
kill the animal it's supposed to be in a
way in which they have the least
suffering
yeah
sounds exactly the same as kosher yeah
like exactly
why why are we always trying to pretend
like they're even different it's the
same [ __ ] sad
everybody's saying you're chewing just
like uh fousey
i know
i wish you guys could taste this
childhood meats
it's good tastes like beef jerky
now we've taken this meme as far as it
can possibly go
i don't think we could take this any
further
this is really good
well thank you baby thank you what a
treat
i'm going in for the lamb one now
the only lamb jerky
in all the united states
according to ronnie
yep
he's uh good guy my family first came
over from lebanon he gave my dad and his
brother a job
even though they were like kids like 12
years old oh child labor in a way but
helped provide for the family he didn't
force them to work right no you know of
course they're not right they're related
distantly so
ronnie's getting old he's his two sons
are running the butcher shop now i mean
he's still there but they're kind of
taking lead now is it a real popular
place in the community
uh yeah it's from like the like the end
of dearborn like borderline detroit
which is kind of out of the way for most
people but they still travel to go see
him even like when they move like 30
minutes away they'll still go back to
that butcher shop because they know it's
clean and it's legit wow yeah ronnie
what's the name of it
ronnie berry's uh hello me market
for anyone in that area
get yourself some meat holy [ __ ]
it tastes like beef jerky it tastes just
like beef turkey wait it is
keep forgetting
that lamb jerky was amazing dude that's
what i'm getting into
oh my god i'm gonna try the hot one now
and then i'll call it today so we can
move on
sorry dan i wanted to bring you
something by the way oh it's okay
you want me to describe it
no i'm just kidding you know what tastes
like them
huh have you ever had beef jerky
yeah of course it tastes just like that
okay yeah i don't remember that it
tastes like beef jerky dan have you ever
had jackfruit jerky
i've had jackfruit many times i don't
know if i've had jerk i
had a period of veganism in my life and
jackfruit
makes a great substitute for beef jerky
if you like season it properly dehydrate
it yeah
interesting we got to try that and bring
the joke there
the turkey tastes like vegan jerky this
joke really paid off though and then now
i'm sitting here and you're doing all
kinds of meal
thank you so much baby i'm very kind of
of course
thank you
enjoy it
if you thanks for the meats
thank you for the meat
maybe thank you to me
[Music]
um
there's a couple other funny things we
could talk about here
the floor is ours pretty much
the wildest mook bang
you guys want doji cat or the wildest
mook bang
let's do a plan
people can choose their own adventure
choose your own adventure
dojo cat
uh
wildest mukbang channel the dojucat one
is just
her getting angry on social media with
people
yeah people being stupid
and her
calling it out mm-hmm
that lame jerky was so moist dude
i love it i've never had anything like
that
you know i never liked lamb
until i lived in israel
and then i understood the lamb
when they cook it right man
oh my god
wildest mukbang channel seems to be the
winner all right
that's the one i wanted anyway
[Music]
so
let me finish chewing i won't do that to
you guys
let's just sit here quietly as a
finisher
we're actually the channel it was it was
a zilli zonk this is the mukbang channel
i'm sad that i can't uh
you guys get to eat and i don't
that's a crime against humanity where i
come from
all right
this channel
is stephanie sue she has 2.7 million
subs
and um
she's a mukbanger with a twist in it
yeah and this seems to be a relatively
recent development on the channel i
noticed because it only started about a
year ago this new angle she seems to
have turned
true crime
and mukbanging crossover i mean
this is uh groundbreaking
his college bully won't leave him alone
mukbang
there's i i i put together some of the
wildest ones in the dock but uh yeah
i'll open that the whole thing is so
here's some of our favorites
check it out
this one's called 42 year old dad
marries his biological daughter and then
kills her
raising cain's tender mukbang
i love that look at this i mean
why not combine these two genres
for fans of both
that's awesome she's so worried about it
too she certainly hasn't lost her
appetite though
another one
how do i wait is there more
i thought there was more
yeah
in the dark
oh just the link to the videos
here's the let's see what goes on inside
of a
i don't know why they're a true crime
mukbang
love it there are so many stepbrother
corn videos out there is there a demand
is the demand that strong why i need to
know this is red flag number one if
you're dating someone and you go into
their room there's like a hole in the
wall they punched it okay i had one he
tried to do a handstand against the wall
and his butt broke the wall so if you
guys want to see an only fans from this
guy coast guard for the past like 30
years now he's working as a corrections
officer out of prison like it seems like
they have a stable life so of course
alyssa okay
you know like yeah i mean if any parents
deserve art in life otherwise you have
no life like that was like okay all
right
some choice thumbnails can uh include
the man
that spread
parasite eggs into buffet food
wagyu beef mukbang girl you cannot
combine those two topics
that was the one that really [ __ ]
killed me this morning who's gonna click
that
who's gonna want to hear about that
while they eat also she's talking about
the the wagyu they're like eating it raw
because it's like that really like high
quality stuff that's supposedly you
don't have to cook so she's like eating
raw beef while talking about parasites
in the food here it is
we terrorize these losers
and they're like oh we're gonna make
this nasty thing that can survive a
nuclear bomb whoa how coach is the
family can survive a nuclear bomb i
don't know if it's no way it's true like
obviously if it explodes on them they
can't but i don't think radiation does
anything to them geez they might even
get stronger you know like mutation
yeah so jack says he takes out the
leeches and lets them suck his blood
but they're not as passion inducing as
now people complain about me being gross
brother eat in
this is a lot more than that
these days his fetish has grown seems
like there's a lot of fans of hers in
our chat
no hate
we're not even yeah we're not hating we
just like
i'm just captivated that title and thumb
just [ __ ] wild stephanie sue's on
fire man i love what you're doing no
hate
i want to see her eat that raw burger
where's that
and they've even touched their food
mukbangs yeah they usually the eating
usually stops like halfway through get
into the food okay so here's the thing
you're like why is there two look at
that i tried to make three i tried to
make three wagyu burgers and
it was the hardest thing in the world
these two barely made it out if i open
the lid if i open the top you're gonna
be like this is so not michelin you just
wanna see look at that
okay well now i'm just watching a
mukbang she's not even talking about the
story but there you have it
gotta have them ribs
okay obama
and a little racial
the cult leader
that was mummified
ramen burger mukbang
hello everyone welcome back to my
channel yeah it's the title and
thumbnail really what's funny 17 year
old killer how a gamer online
friend turned
friends into a killer uh
fries uh
french fry mukbang
prize
i just love that it was a christmas
themed episode
okay a little thin i guess
but shout out
soon
um
i guess we're going to talk about both
dogecat
we talked about it recently what was it
she was
it was the stranger kids thing she had
right with noah schnapp yeah
whoa
just seeing that little pop
snap
yeah doji shaved her head
i mean she's beautiful obviously and i
got no problem with that i mean
obviously how are you gonna have a
problem with what
someone else does with their
hair
um
and i guess
a lot of people a lot of people have
been being rude about it
not surprising
on twitter
i actually haven't seen
me making fun of her oh that ain't right
that's dirty
she shave her eyebrows too
yeah oh my goodness
she did it on instagram live that's a
hard look to pull off i'll tell you from
experience she looks bomb oh right i
forgot that he did that yeah
that is not an easy look but she does it
um
well
anyway she popped off on twitter it was
pretty good
dojicat meet and greet
she was having fun at first with the
memes yeah but they just like kept going
and kept going well this is 170 000
likes yeah
jesus 13 million views what the [ __ ]
yeah it was like that and then slowly
her fans start or like fans started
saying that like they were worried for
her about like because she went on live
without any makeup and she like shaved
her head so i think
all of that
together is what caused her
tweet that is linked i don't think it's
unreasonable to think wonder what like
is she okay no no no for sure but after
because in there is the link to a video
of her saying i'm totally fine like
knock it off
and then people just
ran with it
is built like kid boo
that's
pretty interesting
right
this is just weak
um
fans were saying she needs an
intervention
doji cat got on live without makeup or a
wig
and y'all are saying she needs an
intervention oh okay yeah
totally agree
here she is talking about herself
and and it's just that on top of like
everybody being like
you're on drugs and you're
crazy and what has she done to herself
and
you need help you need like don't be
afraid to like you need to seek help
um
that stuff is so
it's it's really heavy it's a heavy
thing and
it's kind of funny because i like doji
cap
i feel bad for her
i don't think she's still adjusted to
becoming like a mega celeb
because
i think at a certain point
if you want to survive this industry
and not just disappear and retire
you gotta just not be on social media
like she is
you just can't do it
you know that's what that's what austin
did post malone
he used to be on social media all the
time posting memes
and at certain point you just got to
step away you cannot use it like that
because
you you literally cannot live and have a
healthy
mentality healthy state of mind while
reading that kind of [ __ ] about yourself
it's just impossible
it really is
but anyway she dropped the hammer she
had a great tweet cracked me up
oh is this the one i just watched
everybody be
yes so
she dropped a banger tweet
she said
i want i won a grammy and traveled the
[ __ ] globe i've had a number one and
went platinum i make hit after hit after
hit and you all want me to look [ __ ]
so you can go home and jerk your [ __ ]
all day long while you live in your
mom's basement go [ __ ] yourselves i
actually thought
what she said about oh you just want me
to look [ __ ] as was an interesting
observation
you know that's what it is it's like
people are
people love her music she want a grammy
for it she's touring and people are
upset that
she's not
what they want her to look like anymore
because she's still giving everyone the
same [ __ ] that she was giving before
she's on twitter she is on tick tock
she's on live like this was the only
thing that changed mm-hmm
yeah i was i thought that was
interesting but
my advice to dojo cause because i know
you are listening
because you you just gotta
you gotta make that compromise
you just gotta get off social media or
you gotta post and leave you know you
can't engage
you can
it's sad because you want to engage with
your fans and there's a lot of people
that love you and respect you
and want to have a wholesome healthy uh
relationship with you
there's a lot of people
that are just gonna [ __ ] with your head
and make you miserable
so there you have it
here she is
i like dojo i think she's
i think she's interesting and i like how
open she is
but clearly i think that strategy might
be backfiring a little bit
there you have it
anything else guys
i just want to eat this jerky i'm sorry
everyone's probably so mad at me they're
not thrilled maybe
yeah always make me
i have
something maybe i'm gonna send you it
what's your name what you cooking up you
blame me
also get those swirls at a chat i don't
want to see any squirrels no girls also
a small update i
messaged um tony um wally's uh
handler
so to speak
and uh he said that uh wally is getting
the money
um he said something interesting which i
hadn't even thought of because you know
wally's on uh government assistance
so
i guess wally's brother suggested they
are
um
they're doling out the money from the
gofundme in payments so that he doesn't
go over the income threshold and lose
his benefits
and he also said uh he could set up
another uh call and a follow-up um if
we'd like so yeah absolutely because i
do so i guess we're we're x-naying the
the jimmy x wall-e redemption arc
i mean it's a shame because i think it
would be
magic i don't want to
say no don't help wally
but
are there under maybe just a dentist in
but like super expensive
right it's like a huge operation
gotcha
well then i don't know
and the people said no more jimmy so i
said once a year yeah sorry jimmy has he
texted you by the way zach
uh the last communication was
um what he said you know
uh tell dan same tell dana mo cam just
character like i said and then the last
one was don't knock me out of the box
zacker
we're not you just you gotta we once he
once a year buddy
you're in the penalty box now yeah
he's
six month hiatus
all right well we learned a lot today
i am part of a underground pedophile
ring
based on the
there's a sound bite
your voice is turning into alex jones
kind of
i got some jerky stuck in my throat
but we had fun didn't we folks we had a
good time we had a good time how long
we've been going
two and a half hours okay it's a short
one but i'm out of sight for one
i guess lately that's a short one yeah
uh but we exhausted our dock we got
nothing
austin mcbroom
lost his lawsuit to beverly hills
we talked about that beverly yeah yeah
wait i don't know if we're applauding
that anymore did you we're good with him
now discord
we're good with austin but
you guys remember
that um
beverly hills city is suing austin for
mobbing melrose and effectively shutting
it down
they want to
yeah that's what i thought they only owe
them 21 000. it's not even that much
money i mean it's a lot of money
obviously but
it's just to cover the time for all the
cops they sent to like crowd control and
stuff
i thought he'd i thought he would get
way more punished than that you're
telling me i could shut down rodeo drive
for a whole day for 20 000 bucks that's
a good deal a year ago the city of
beverly hills said that they wanted 200
000 from them
and then they got 25.
wow
good deal yeah it's always better to ask
for forgiveness and ask for permission
oh what's this phillyd update uh he made
a his latest video he talks about cobra
tate for
about 10 minutes
and he mentions the assault charges the
allegations of
holding a girl against her would you
throw it to the audience or does he uh
vote they offer his own opinion
no he seems pretty firm on tape let's
pull it up i mean let's see what he's
got today
took him long enough corbin's already
like a dead moon
happened even faster than i thought it
would
he's gone i'm telling you
andrew tate is gone
but let's see what philly do you stop
you beautiful baptist say i'm sorry
about this beef jerky
beautiful bastards welcome back to the
philip defranco show make sure to
subscribe because i'm going to be
splitting 10 000 across 10 lucky
subscribe beautiful bastards this month
and let's just jump in whoa
i philly's gotten desperate for those
subs maybe we got to take a a leaf out
of his book
listen to this sup you beautiful
bastards welcome back to the philip
defranco show make sure you subscribe
because i'm going to be splitting ten
thousand dollars across ten lucky
subscribe beautiful bastards this month
and let's just jump dude
are we subscribed
[ __ ] i'm jumping on
gifted
i want that 10k
yeah i'm not paying anybody to survive
my channel
and i'm losing subs like they
[ __ ] halloween candy with the hole at
the bottom of your bag well you know
maybe we could take notes from philly i
dude i don't think this [ __ ] ever works
paying people to subscribe people just
come
sub and then bail
like it's not a meaningful change to
your audience
which is what matters ultimately not
subs
you know what you mean
gp's up you got ideas baby for how we
can stop the the leak i i don't know how
i feel about the philly slander that's
it
i'm not playing
he's a genius he's a skinny legend
yeah i say we got to say like and
subscribe early on
and if you don't want to do it because
it's cringe let me in love do it blow it
down
anyway we already tested it
we did it for like a week it didn't do
anything
i'm sorry guys i'm trying not to anyway
let's see what philly does this here
been doing the first thing that we're
going to talk about today is all this
news surrounding a man who whether you
love him or hate him it feels like
thanks to the algorithm on all these
platforms we have been forced to learn
about over the past few months and that
is andrew tate i'm getting dms from what
appear to be early teen boys saying i
hope andrew tate destroys you so that
was australian television and radio
personality abby chatfield we're going
to get back to later and she's talking
about former kickboxer turned massive
online personality andrew tate and tate
as it turns out has actually been around
for quite a while now but over the past
several weeks and months he's just blown
up in a crazy way or just looking at
google search trends over the summer
search has skyrocketed for him outpacing
those of people with massive followings
like joe rogan and a-list stars like
taylor swift so with that kind of
following you're like can you run that
i'm curious what it looks like now
because i feel like again
his popularity has got to be dropping
off big time
i don't know after visiting home
it's a different world
yeah like okay well what is he known for
what genius is he putting out there into
the world for me i think my first
introduction to tate was this dave
portnoy clip where he's just like the
woman is going out with a man she
belongs to that man that's his woman so
she wants to do only fan she owes him
some money because she's his yes
well that's crazy you think it's
crazy so it's reverse uh male porn star
always the woman
i don't know
i think
yeah
just watch we got to keep checking in on
this this thing's gonna bottom out soon
shout out to kosovo number one
what's going on over there
it's north macedonia macedonia
macedonia
okay you don't have to say it's so
patronizing
albania
lately
okay cool
woman's that's inherently where you get
called sexes i didn't think that he was
being real like i was like this has to
be a character because this is you know
what i'm gonna be honest
he's a little late to the game on this
one
like
[Music]
is there anything in here does anyone
watch this
no that just came out i
went through it on double speed but
towards the end he talks more about the
allegations it ends around the 10-minute
mark
all right well
you were fishing i tried to throw you a
fish
thank you paul miller of the tiny meat
gang podcast initially saying he should
just be ignored who cares yeah
i know that's a really hot take but
people get really worked up like oh this
guy doesn't like girls he's like so what
it's like leave him in romania and like
talking to himself
yeah i disagree with that take
but i understand it's not a big deal
you know
doesn't mean i hate him because i
disagree with that thing but
andrew tate is like actively [ __ ] a
whole generation of men right now
well i know but the problem is he's not
in romania talking to himself he's
talking to
okay millions and millions of
community of boys whatever
phil you're late
where were you when we needed you
that's enough for a highlight anyways i
think yeah
we got a clickbait like phillyd is a
slob loser beta
skinny legend king welcome back to
promotion
what is this someone else just sent me a
video jake paul gets in a street fight
with milk boy yep
okay this is interesting who's steiny
he's in elk
i want to see which kid this is
this is the homie who was oh it's that
yeah this is our oh it's the the elden
lord yeah
the shooter
this is the legendary
steiny who
who was asking the hardest hitting
questions i've ever seen
i'm gonna send it
what console you played on
wait this guy got a fight with jake he
can get destroyed didn't he
yeah he's jake is like in the clip on
top of him he's way bigger is this does
anyone screen this
don't show this is probably way too
violent to show on the show he did
anyone watch it
i mean he's just so no he's just
ragdolling him it looks like
yeah if you're gonna send a fight video
you gotta you gotta watch that first you
know why they were fighting he was
asking uh he was telling him to say he's
sorry
he was asking jake if he's if he's ever
heard of eldon ring
cool in this clip that is now making a
tour of the internet jake paul's
allegedly seen fighting steiny from milk
the lights in the camera angle make it
hard to spot either of them according to
fads the one
entity entity on top is jake and the
other on the ground is steiny poor stang
is referred to as an entity yeah they
say the one entity on top is jake
[Laughter]
someone's been playing alvin ring
there's not much to it seems like jake's
just holding him down yeah he's just
there are no punches that's awesome okay
um
yeah people have been uh bringing up
i can't believe we haven't talked about
this yet
um what do you think about your two
besties going behind your back
oh jeff and hassan yeah it's sacrilege
completely ridiculous yeah his song goes
goes in secret on his other podcast
and he has jeff on i'm like bro you got
it
i got did you not ask my permission
first like kim start with the cotton
candy
is there someone you forgot to ask
actually apparently they're buddies i
didn't know that they're like old
buddies
wait really
that's what hassan said when i was like
yo what the [ __ ] cap
you think that's a lie
what is this
he didn't he didn't mention that when
you guys were talking about jeff on the
podcast the other day
don't you think that would have been
i just think it's a little weird
that he's all hurt
about
jeff being bff material and then
two days later
yeah they are oh no we go way back
dude he won the poll and yeah right way
back and honestly hassan's defense he
talked about going on that flight once
with some of the vlog squad back in the
day
right he said he didn't know anybody
listen jeff should have known better at
the end of the day he's voted my number
one bestie recurring times by this
audience and he's going to go
on a podcast with hassan so i'm saying
jeff it's [ __ ] up you coming into my
home
we break bread we break jerky
we talk about family and life
you say i inspired you
you've been voted my best friend twice
by this beautiful
audience that we love
and now my friend
you broke my heart you go to the sounds
podcast
i'll tell you what jeff
[Music]
if you see me on the tractor you better
not get on
oh because we got a problem
me and you after all i've done for you
it's an excavator excavator excavator
i'll tell you what jeff i'll make you
blind in both eyes if you cross me again
i know it was you freedom
you blink of my heart
dude hassan doesn't have a friendship
bracelet seriously
i guess maybe we should get him one
yeah maybe that's where it's all
stemming from oh
true
you have these matching you have these
matching bracelets with all your besties
but what about what about this bed and
ethan's defense they're matching cars
best cars oh that's that is that's
commitment that's bestie behavior
because we know never mind
hassan
i thought we were better friends than
this
people are spamming not funny
[ __ ] your mom and that's why i don't
read the chat
um people really want me to talk about
deaf noodles i just don't really know
how to touch that topic so i'm just
avoiding it that's just the honest
answer there
you know
he seems to be
i don't know how to say it it just seems
like
some people got the best of him
you know
i wish he wouldn't get baited so
frequently into
doing stuff that
people can you know use against him
i don't know the thing is i like i like
dennis he's a homie you know we talked
we did the steamies together
obviously there's stuff that he said and
done on social media that's like way too
far
even for me but i but he's my friend so
i'm not gonna like
yo is my hairline receding look at that
no it's not
why is it so high you were quick with
that no maybe because maybe this whole
uh this whole arc of you being a good
guy now maybe it's something literally
recede
yo does that look like a receding
hairline or not a little bit it's the
lighting
it's the lighting love says you're the
man bro you're getting a promotion
you're thinking you're the new producer
i don't need him let me see this side
what
that side looks okay right
yeah you gotta start talking some more
[ __ ] quick you're just flexing is what
you're doing right now
i don't know i saw this and it's i
stopped that in my tracks i was like yo
that looks a little receded
have i lost one hair
meanwhile all of us are just receding
centimeters every year wait are you
receding love i didn't wear and where i
have a little bit of um like widow's
peak
but not too crazy
not too crisp i wish the best for you
but thank you thank you i'm not too
close
that we should make hassan a friendship
bracelet and then
maybe we could be three-way besties so
jeff hassan ethan do you know what
colors yours and hassan's friendship is
i would say pink and white pink and
white got it
i say you just get one that says jeff
loves ethan
yeah i'll put a tracking device in that
bracelet though obviously
i'll know if he ever goes there again
yeah but about the jet the death noodles
thing
[Music]
i don't know i just wish he wouldn't get
baited that's all i have to say really
i don't know if he's going through stuff
i don't know
what
but
sometimes the internet gets the best of
you
i've been there before
and i know how it feels it's horrible it
feels horrible
so i definitely don't want to dog pile
up on him
uh but
i just hope that you know it's like you
know what i mean he lets the internet
get the best of him what was that i
wasn't looking
i'd rock it i'd rock it
yeah you'd be fine
nothing what could be worse than what
i've already got
thank you ian thank you
i'm growing my hair back people
yeah def said well people keep
oh yeah somebody's told deaf noodles he
commented that you're embarrassing h3 i
was like
stupid i don't care about that
he's not embarrassing me i mean he's his
own man it's just crazy he said
it's not
we're not each other's responsibility
that's true obviously
but
yeah i don't know i just hope that
he
just stops getting baited and just you
know makes content
he says it doesn't bother him but maybe
it's true i mean i don't know the
intimate
intimate thoughts he has but
when i got into that [ __ ] it i was
miserable like when i was getting baited
by the internet and just being angry and
trying to like one-up the trolls
trying to own the trolls whatever you
just it's [ __ ] miserable bro i've in
my experience
it's the worst place
be trolling it's called we do a little
do
to
trolling
um
yeah i don't know
but uh
remember guys he hasn't done anything to
anyone really it's just words on the
internet so don't i mean he said some
pretty vile things to be honest about
the like
kill yourself the end of a shotgun i
didn't like that
i don't know why he'd push it like that
but
just remember guys he didn't really do
anything okay
besides
tell those horrible jokes
but i'm just saying
let's all take a let's take a measured
breath here he just
if you think he's cringe or not funny or
you don't like his content or do you
think he's going crazy he didn't do
anything right he's not a criminal
so that's the thing
but that we got to remember when we talk
about people on the internet
someone says yes he has what has he done
except in your opinion be cringe
he supported a predator what does that
mean
oh he called someone a
yeah wait what who did he do that
he i believe it was uh
yeah
oh yeah that was [ __ ] up that was
[ __ ] up
that's like how it all started but i
think
yeah that was [ __ ] up that was that
was silly that's what i'm saying i wish
she just he didn't he doesn't have to
get baited into all this crap
you know do you call him a better or you
just say look he said i think he said he
looks like a pedo and then he got into
that's kind of what
was spiraled out of control because he's
like
i was joking that he looked like a pedo
which for the record is a huge
difference you could say someone looks
like a pedo
is not the same as saying someone is a
pedo obviously right and get no swirls
in chat guys
now's not the time for swirls okay i'm
already on the edge with these
conspiracy theorists
no [ __ ] squirrels
he sold a t-shirt with papa gut crying
yeah it's tasteless but i mean at the
end of the day it's just the internet
you guys
i i'm saying it's fully in your right to
not like him to not watch him say he's
cringe whatever
but
um
just remember that you know
but he said did he ever say he was a
pedo or did you just say he looked like
a beto that's a big difference
i don't honestly know i'm i'm not up to
date on the situation it's
yeah it's gone pretty it's gone it's
yeah it's hard like every interaction
i've ever had with him was lovely he was
always really kind and you know he's
always been supportive uh then i've just
been checked out but i just people keep
spamming
uh the chat my chat whenever i go live
on instagram wherever it is or in my
comment section probably all of us
comment on definitely the subreddit is
totally saturated with it like
at the end of the day i mean i can't
speak for you but he doesn't he doesn't
work here you know like i don't yeah
yeah
but
i don't know i like him
he's gone too far you know as a friend
it's like you gotta you literally yeah
the fbi people keep saying yeah that's a
joke yeah it's stupid man
it's a dumb joke saying you look like a
pedo and tagging the fbi that's not like
on twitter that's not that serious yeah
it's
just saying obviously yeah again i don't
know if there's other stuff but
everybody's saying he tagged the fbi who
gives a [ __ ] that's like you tag people
as a joke on twitter all the time
some people are saying he said he looks
like one
right that was what i had heard is that
he looks like one i mean the tweet that
got it all started it's was you look
like a pedo i think
here let's see let's get to the okay now
we're in it so let's just [ __ ] look
into this boy do we have to
we're gonna get out of here
here is the tweet in question
[Laughter]
got this [ __ ] ready bro
yeah that's i'm just saying dennis if
you're watching that this is what
happened to jordan okay
he
he gets too lost in the sauce man delete
the hateful tweet in question death
noodles accuses papa gut of being a pedo
over an old joke he made years ago
and has since apologized for
it's getting pretty intense between them
here's some of papa's responses
so so he did say that i guess i need the
source footage
this is a whole [ __ ] quagmire bro
papa said i don't really want to get
exactly we're not prepared to talk about
it none of us have really been paying
attention to it it's like
it's just you're getting baited right
now by the trolls you're you're you're
doing a dentist yeah no i'm not
i'm i'm i'm kidding obviously i just i
said what i wanted i said what i wanted
to say out of all this the real tragedy
is
we're talking about we're saying you're
down we didn't even put in the thumbnail
god we didn't even put in the title you
think people have clicked for that
they've been down playing all right
we're downplaying this guys
dude this is why i said i don't want to
talk about it there's already weirdos in
the chat that are like
flipping out
yeah this is why i avoided talking about
it because it's like
it's a lose-lose right
no matter what i say
um
don't read the chat somebody's going to
have something in there [ __ ] off you're
a weirdo but to be honest
get banned [ __ ]
dan's banning people who'd you been
somebody who said i'm the [ __ ] worst
oh you got banned by dan bye bye god
wham one beer
who did you banned before that was funny
oh yeah he's in the [ __ ] nether realm
i've essentially been banned from
twitter
look guys at the end of the day don't
quote me on that i don't know and it is
what it is i don't know you know what i
mean what the [ __ ] you want from me
and that's that the last thing i said is
i don't want to talk about it because
i don't know what the [ __ ] leave me
alone dude exactly it's just like i want
you if you want to be really mad about
it on the internet
go ahead it's not
he doesn't work here
he goes yeah
i got nothing to do with the guy i mean
we're friendly
we're friends
oh my god like can we talk about like
the political yeah
thank you talk about what's going on
with the environment can we talk about
other things
thank you
you look like you want to say something
maybe not just say a good summary of the
chat not all of them but some of them is
earlier someone named morgan smith said
amy how dare you let jimmy make camel
jokes a girl your name is morgan smith
chill the [ __ ] out
morgan smith white ass yeah please
please
most people are upset he's getting so
angry and yelling at fans saying we're
all fake
watch his two newest videos yeah i mean
that [ __ ] sucks i wish he wasn't doing
that
so
is he really i just want to peek at his
channel real fast i'm not going to watch
anything i'm not going to get baited
i just want to see she said watch his
last two videos i was going to look at
the title and thumbnail
here we are i juggle let's see
addressing the tweets that got me
canceled addressing the new allegations
i guess
yeah it doesn't say much does it
you know i wish him well he's my friend
i hope he reels it in gets his [ __ ]
together and stops
causing problems
he got an injury set
like that
give me the [ __ ] alone
find a way to spend anything i say
yo he's a pedo apologist well what
yeah for sure
yep
draw the most insane conclusion
yeah
those swirls were pretty convincing no
no convincing
no [ __ ] squirrels
but the truth is what's really going on
is there's a there's a group of
commentary channels that are just
for them it's like a feeding frenzy
nerdy [ __ ] bullies yeah they're just
it's a feeding frenzy and they're
they got a big old [ __ ] meal out of
this now at the end of the day
it's probably all they care about
to eat
you know
it's like all the people going
like he's he's acting cringe posting
[ __ ] like that or whatever but all the
people that he's beeping with are like
some of the most annoying horrible
people on the internet too so don't
really want to like throw them a bone
either so that's what i just did just
that's the headline of all their new
videos now exactly
dan does not speak for me
although i will call him wan
get those worlds out of chat they're
gonna blame me for that
ethan's a pedo apologist spamming swirls
in chat
why does youtube have a pedo swirl emoji
a puffer fish right it goes deeper than
that isn't that just like a default
emoji those are for cinnamon rolls so
the conspiracy goes even deeper it's
like the em the emoji corporation itself
whoever determines the emojis
spiral
emoji ethan you've been in with youtube
don't you did you include the swirls oh
i gotta ask i gotta go is that you it
wasn't me man
i gotta dig deeper though
oh it's a cyclone cyclone emoji
can you guys call me wheat thins
it's like ethan with a w you know wheat
thins i know wheat thins sweet thin
wheat thins
all right this this shows ended on such
a pointless
why you brought it up
all right guys call me wheat then from
now on
wheat thin yeah w ethan w ethan
i love wheat thins that's pretty good
they're so good
i have a little bit of a
thing to say i have beef with swedish
mcdonald's oh my god
yeah the
i
eat fika right and i stay up working at
night obviously
and i like to go and grab a little bit
of a burger at night right some midnight
feet last night
turns out bro the only restaurant in the
city that is open 24 7
stopped having opened 24 7 mcdonald's
guys oh my [ __ ] god wow why would
they do that
i went there in the middle of the night
yesterday
and it's [ __ ] close i have to go to
the gas station and eat [ __ ] glitzy
or something like that
well you'll be happy to see this um
while one
opportunity closes another one opens the
world's tiniest mcdonald's just opened
it
but it's only for bees
yeah
it's been open for a while i think
only for bees love yeah it's nice so
it's nice to look at
they got good little combo deals for the
bees
yeah love that
but please guys help me reopen this
mcdonald's i don't know what to do let
me probe a little bit when you go there
in the middle of the night is it is
there other people there
a couple every now and then yeah that
doesn't sound good
come on now
the hard-working people of my city needs
to eat it's more of a it's more of a
public service you would say than true i
had i had a
there's a viewer that is uh that works
at mcdonald's
and she said that
they closed all restaurants in sweden
during night or or the mcdonald's or
restaurants because they are opening
they're saving money for something
called
um
mac cafe
and i think that sounds like a waste
i don't know yo this is insane we got to
drive this all the way up to the prime
minister
yeah i think so the president there's
royalty we got to tell the royalty
yeah
the ss i just need to get it to the king
and i
when he hears about this because and
pewdiepie too he's the other royalty of
sweden yes yes yes yeah
does the king
is the king on twitter
and i don't think so he kind of is like
a little bit of a boomer i think yeah
i love him though he's a nice guy
the king's a little bit of a boomer what
do you do for you lately nice guy
uh he's just entertaining the swedish
people you know uh swedish royal family
is not that you know controversial the
most controversial thing is that he
probably like
smoked a cigar or something like that a
guard i think he's gonna be a guardian
he's a gargoyle
the vibe right now do you think the king
has the authority to keep that
mcdonald's open
i think he could help in the matter you
could stand for sure let's take this to
the king they'll go up like gandalf and
just
you shall not close yes yes fly you
fools we need but i've been planning to
put write like a long letter and put it
on the door
like martin luther king right yeah i
will do that and i will prove that look
at you
i want to see that yeah okay this is
that mcdonald's that i'm talking about
that happened
that's kind of insane that you're able
to keep put that sideways without it
exploding well no wonder they [ __ ]
closed love you took all their patties
man they ran out of food oh
happened to me right after i emailed
them saying that i would come back for
40.
i was
and they just closed
well
if you're planning to post your uh
manifesto on the doors like martin
luther king
martin luther king
i'd like to film that i want to i want i
will see that for sure hollowed moments
that's a beautiful moment absolutely and
that's bringing and that's power to the
people right there that's just taking it
to the man yeah and i mean at the end of
the day this is like 90 of my streaming
content too so right i have a little bit
of uh
uh incentive to keep this restaurant
open you know
yeah now if you guys maybe signed some
kind of uh
decree some kind of
alliance where you would guarantee to
buy a hundred hamburgers every night
would you be willing to do that
well i mean
honestly yes i think so yeah okay every
couple maybe 50 and i don't say
yeah so if we can get the management on
the phone potentially we could brokers
some kind of agreement
yeah i mean i'll keep them open you know
my my my traffic alone will will
probably be able to
can we actually get a hold of the
management i wonder if we can actually
work on this well yeah i mean i started
like a what's it called one of those
where you click the butt uh
petition where you petition yes yes a
petition
it's somewhere i don't know it has like
50
signs
no but seriously uh you guys send the
address to the team behind the stage and
we're going to try to get a hold of the
management because i do feel like
there's a path here
for um redemption
and understanding i'd love to see you
get on the phone with the manager and
try to work it out live
well yeah i mean i would when we're done
with sweden can we get one of the places
in la because there's no places open
past midnight another fast food place
mcdonald's
that ain't true
but there's definitely something this is
what we got bro this is all we have bro
that makes sense but no nothing where i
live there's only one and it's sonic's
and i hate it
why i swear mcdonald's like 24. nothing
for us either
where we are thank you sam we are always
complaining about it i am the night out
ten o'clock you cannot find food after
you got you got canned deli
in your apartment i'm not gonna go get
canters down they deliver yeah
some family member here said that it
opens in fall let's go i hope by the way
i don't want to forget to thank my good
friend
mecca
donia
for the 50 gifted thank you for the
gifted
yeah i'm serious about this love there's
got to be something we can do
and i'm going to appreciate your
seriousness thank you very much and
because right now i am a little bit
hungry and i don't want to make food
i got you bro
you know yes
he's a gamer he needs stuff on the fly
i'm hungry and i do not want to make
food i gotta say too man it's just not
right love is an excellent chef too he's
not just being lazy thank you he he puts
time and effort into his meals and i
don't blame him for nothing is that
right yeah
yeah i'm actually pretty good i want to
explain
no offense i just don't know why
what what kind of stuff did you cook for
cameron
uh well we i didn't well i guess he
for whatever reason we ate at separate
times some usually but he usually came
by
i gave him some test taste yeah you let
me have a nibble on like the
what was it called
yep i met i made some good stuff and
well yeah
but it takes effort for what you make
you put time and love and care into it
and you know sometimes you just need
some mcdonald's too thank you yes yes
yes i agree
all right this is our new project so
make sure to send that address if we
can't get a hold of it we'll we'll hire
some attorneys local attorneys
to get their information we're going to
get to the bottom of this and hopefully
right do you think we could get a carl
gustav meal too like the travis scott
meal
oh the king of sweden very possible very
possible yeah that'd be fire
sweden mcdonald's has like a rotating
menu too so they like wow seasonal menu
yeah like every two or three months they
have new burgers they have they have
fried chicken on the um
on the bone there too that blew my mind
what yeah it blew my mind
whoa
hot wings yeah
so we're gonna get to the bottom of this
love i get i promise you that
thank you very much [ __ ] fried
chicken love always talks about a
chicken tasty that sounds amazing she
can taste this much chicken tasty yeah
she can taste all right listen guys i
could talk about mcdonald's all day long
but it is 420 blades almost 420.
so we got to get
i lived on the island
and wait let me catch my groove
i i'm gonna teach my group
eight eight one two one two three four
here you go
i come from jamaica
and i like to spark the blunt
it don't matter if it's rain or sun
i want to smoke that blunt every day
i light
that blunt
let me be blunt
all my family smoke plant
no mcdonald's no fries
my son who's two years old
he smoked a blunt
in the morning
he smoked they blunt that night
[Music]
smoking big joints in amish
we out here doing the ding dongs
we smoking every day
i get high and drive and forget where i
was going
i smoke a joint and get in my car it's
[ __ ] nice out
i black out and end up at a spot
i can't remember driving anywhere that's
because i smoked two blunts before i
smoked two blunts two four
chattana he's parking it up for the good
ones i
[Music]
yeah
yeah throw that up on spotify eat your
heart out
all right guys
it's all downhill it's not getting any
better
it's getting worse and worse
so with that being said we wish you all
a fabulous evening thank you for sharing
your day here with us at the h3 podcast
we will be back
regular schedule
wednesday thursday friday you know the
drill
um see you then guys
[Music]
do
[Music]
you